so apparently there's no news at all
today because the only thing I'm seeing
is like clips from yesterday's show and
they're like Tim pull this Tim pull that
and it's just like oh geez no it was
saying Sheamus and Ian this and Sheamus
no Sheamus we were so no Sheamus we this
lamest this is that's right that was a
good one Sheamus thanks buddy so we we
do have news though um the big story
right now that everyone's talking about
this week is the the Jordan Neely uh
story this is the homeless guy who was
attacking people there's new new
evidence has come out uh of his past
behaviors and once again the left is
doubling down on the uh grand jury
should indict the man who was defending
himself and others from this uh violent
individual so we'll definitely talk
about that and then it was a funnier
story that I thought maybe we should
lead with Donald Trump's rape trial
deposition has been released into a
certain extent and there's a clip where
he roasts the opposition lawyer saying
like he says something like you you
wouldn't be good enough for me quite
frankly and it's just it's really funny
that he's being deposed and he tells the
female lawyer that she's not good enough
to for him to like want to sleep with I
just think that's kind of funny so it's
Friday we're chilling we're going to
talk about what's going on with this uh
the politics stuff I think some of the
uh there's gonna be some conversation
about what the whole thing last night
because we've been talking about it all
day and basically everybody else's
before we get started my friends today's
episode of Tim castells brought to you
by cast brew coffee take a look at this
beautiful bag go to castbrew.com and
pick up your coffee today I gotta tell
you normally a dark roast guy and we
have Appalachian nights a robust dark
blend it's pretty it's up there it's
pretty dark but I started drinking the
light roast rise with Roberto Jr it's
very bright and and nutty and I'm a big
fan now this is what I'm into with every
purchase of rise with Roberto Jr you'll
get a picture of Roberto Jr right there
in the back and I know that you all will
love and cherish that picture of our
rooster Roberto Jr so support the show
go to castbrew.com pick up your coffee
to support the show we're sponsoring
ourselves and this is going to be the
coffee brand for our new uh line of
cafes we got these really awesome bags
I'm really excited for so thank you for
your support and become a member at
timcast.com by clicking join us and uh
hang out in our Discord server with
like-minded individuals Monday through
Thursday you can even call in to our
uncensored members only show and we will
be having very soon uh maybe within the
next week the launch of our new
documentaries Channel because joining us
today to talk about this and so much
more is Lauren Southern
happy to be here and you uh just
completed a documentary yes for us Tim
cast original infringed uh great timing
with Biden repeatedly tweeting about how
we need to ban assault rifles because
we've been going all across the States
from Baltimore to Texas to unfortunately
Berkeley uh interviewing people night
crawling and figuring out what's been
going on with the gun control stuff here
and it's a pretty epic documentary an
hour and 40 minutes of deep diving on
the ground footage and John yes yeah do
you want to introduce yourself yeah well
I'm John du toy uh I'm a filmmaker and
uh you know I uh I make music as well uh
you know I I'm just some you know I like
doing art and uh yeah right on and
filmmaking so you guys uh Lauren and
John have produced infringed we do have
another documentary so in the next two
weeks we should have two full-length
documentaries come out the second is by
Ben Stewart and Harrison Schultz and
it's about the Federal Reserve in
banking and I just feel like we got
really lucky with this because the gun
control thing is is is is happening now
and we we talked about doing this we
pitched this uh like six seven months
ago and the same thing with the Federal
Reserve documentary and now the banks
are all collapsing so it's just like wow
we we really saw the future here and
having this come out in the next couple
weeks would be really great so that'll
be at timcast.com we're gonna be putting
Clips up on youtube.com timcast and then
the full length for members only on
timcast.com so there will be powerful
select moments when the documentaries
released and then you know we're hoping
that this can be something sustainable
and we can keep making more
documentaries but we're already getting
ready for the next set so thank you guys
for hanging out smash the like button we
almost got we we also got almost guys
I don't think I could do tonight's show
no Tim wasn't offering enough in the way
of whiskey Sheamus has three four
bottles of booze in front of him and I
drank all of them that's why they're
empty it's not like former guests have
been just mix it all together Tim I went
over there and there were these insanely
expensive bottles and Tim said you just
only take the really cheap stuff Sheamus
because you know we don't value you
Sheamus tried drinking the cheap stuff
and I was like famous we got a 25 year
Scotch right what are you doing that's
actually true I feel bad I don't want to
crack open your 25 year Scotch
it's just like you know I don't really
want to open the expensive ones you know
what I mean and I'm like no
the difference between men and women
Lauren's like is it bad if I mix the
diet coke into the 25-year scotch and
yeah and I was like no I encourage it I
recommend it is that what you're doing
that's the plan after we finish this one
please don't do that please do not some
traditions have to be protected my
goodness the whiskey aficionados are
watching the show and every time Lauren
comes on they're like
I want you to Pappy out
blaspheme against the Glenn Lavette is
that what it's called yeah Levitt Glenn
levette The Glenn Lavette XXV 25 years
well anyway my name is Sheamus coagul
and I have a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes where we make animated
cartoons I also have a podcast called
shamer it's on Rumble twice a week
Tuesdays and Thursdays at 6 p.m Eastern
nice branding man thank you I was just
gonna say you can really tell I'm not
media trained it's like once you
introduce yourself I'm like hi I'm just
a guy yeah happy to be here I'm also
just a guy we got Moon Lord over here
Jordan Moon Lord we're going to the Moon
we're going to build a space elevator on
the moon Michael Lane's already been
working on it with Spaceport so I'm
going to be happy to ride that thing
speaking of riding right disappointed
when you realize the moon isn't real oh
boy you think the moon's Hollow I've
heard it's tall it's a space station
yeah haven't you seen that movie
moonfall or whatever it's called it's a
holiday where the Moon is falling to
Earth and it turns out the whole moon is
a space station that created Earth and
Ancient Aliens humans actually built it
I think it's the result of a planet
colliding with Earth a long time ago and
coming out the other end as a ball of
magma that just cooled down over time
that's why it's held magnetically just
between us and the sun creating a
perfect Eclipse gravitational but that
is the perfect introduction for Ian so
this is magnetism sounds like it's like
a conspiracy theory to me it's funny
when people are like Tim's show is weird
because he has like Sheamus and Ian on
yeah yeah Moon Lord tune Lord dudes also
we got Serge dupriya hello how's it
going guys excited for the show it's
like the least weird guy I know let's uh
let's let's jump into this first story
so the big news that's been happening
all week that the the left seems to be
latching onto and is a really good
example of anarcho tyranny is uh this
dude Jordan Neely who died after he was
choked and he was subdued and then
choked on the train and we got this new
story from the New York Post and 9-1-1
flooded with calls including reports of
a gun while Jordan nearly was fatally
choked on train they say a total of five
emergency calls were made over four
minute span just before 2 30 P.M Monday
when now identified 24 year old Daniel
Penny held kneeling a chocolate on the
floor of the Northbound F train the
first call came in at 226 was reporting
a physical fight on the subway followed
by another one minute later someone
reporting on the train threatening
writers so it sounds like this guy
nearly had already attacked people then
was threatening people because
you can't have one call come in and then
a call come in after
right so it's so people are saying the
original story was that Neely was
threatening people and then he got
subdued sounds like he attacked people
then when it stopped went on to threaten
people and then later a third caller uh
uh uh said he was armed with a knife or
a gun
it was unclear whom the callers
referring to though Nelly Neely or penny
so we don't know for sure but I really
don't think they're talking about the
three men who subdued this guy now
what's end up what's ended up happening
is I think I have a tweet from AOC she
tweets I have yet to hear a real
explanation from any official hesitating
to condemn the killing of Jordan Neely
about what makes condemning this
violence so complicated it's not
complicated there's nothing that here's
I'll tell you this AOC make it easy for
you I condemn Jordan Neely's violence I
condemn your soft on crime policies that
resulted in 25 people last year being
shoved in front of trains with two of
them dying I condemn you and your
actions and I commend the man the men
who's tried stopping this violent man
and I am sad that Jordan nearly lost his
life was that so difficult
I hand it to you panel
I mean this is also something we're
seeing a lot in my city of Vancouver
first of all I think public transport is
very quickly becoming a human rights
violation we just had an Isis stabbing
where a teenager had his throat slit on
the subway another uh gentleman killed I
probably a lot of you probably saw the
Starbucks stabbing in Vancouver what no
you didn't see it so it was always
footage some guy was fatally stabbed in
front of his toddler because he asked a
guy to stop vaping and it was actually
with a religious knife from a Sikh
gentleman I think in broad daylight in
Vancouver and it's all of these people
this was like two three weeks ago whoa
um it's a whole lot of people with
mental health issues that keep being
released on the street 40 individuals
this was last year committed over 3 000
crimes in one year in Vancouver and they
can't figure it out they can't figure
out what to do you give that list of 40
people to a toddler and they can tell
you what to do with it put them in jail
put them in jail if they have committed
oh I did see this right I did see this
story I did not realize that's what had
what had caused it yeah I just saw the
video is like whoa that guy got stabbed
yo and he's just watching as the dude
bleeds out yeah he asked him no no but
none of that's ever condemned right the
fact that we live in a culture that
doesn't see this is out of the ordinary
but loses its mind when somebody tries
to defend themselves is never condemned
by any of these political leaders who
claim to care so much about human life
no it's because they're evil right yeah
so it's like it's like listen like
I'll use traditional comic book and
cartoon lore the villain is the one like
the Joker releasing the inmates from
prison and then laughing as the inmates
terrorize people and then when the super
Evolution man when the superhero stops
the criminals they go no they get mad
that it's happening that's literally
what we're seeing ocasio-cortez is a
comic book villain she is Lex Luthor she
pretends to be of the people they all
celebrate her that's quite literally
what Lex Luthor represented he was the
perfect villain for Superman because he
didn't have superpowers he controlled
social Society through corporations and
wealth and means AOC is certainly not
extremely wealthy but she uses her
influence to defend the the criminals
and condemn the victims she lied about
January 6 and she's trying to condemn
innocent people now politicians need to
be forced to take the subway every day
if they have an opinion like that if
they think that he was the victim in
this situation obviously I think no one
should have been put in this situation
everyone was the victim of an extremely
broken system yeah like but but in the
moment the man who is threatening people
is the perpetrator yeah I don't care if
you're like but he's mentally ill so
what well he never should have been out
there running around on the bus
threatening people in the first place
institutions for these people exactly
there needs to be institutions for these
people we need to have real Frank
conversations about what has to be done
about the decline of mental health in
the United States that aren't just let's
say nice platitudes and throw money at a
system that isn't going to actually do
anything and especially when you have
political leaders like AOC who want for
there to be National Mass public transit
from one side of the nation to the other
with these massive Railways and they're
not even doing anything to ensure that
the mass transit in their own cities are
are safe for people or is safe for
people it's like okay now you want this
to be the only option people have on a
national scale you want to start to
slowly do away with highways and ensure
that the only way people can get across
the country is by riding these Railways
when the railways in your city are
extremely dangerous and you're not doing
anything to make I'm safe I think one
thing that could be done is that we
could do some sort of prison reform
where we start putting webcams in
prisons for inmates that are supervised
and allow them to communicate with
therapists and family so we really do
turn it into a sort of
um I don't know a place where people can
actually become better as opposed to
just retribution and Vengeance and we
want them we don't want people to suffer
in prison we want them to become better
humans but I can take it one step
further I I just I realized this the
other day very very simple solution if
you break the law you are uh we
forcefully give you the meta the the
neuralink implant and then plug you in
and delete from your brain criminality
dude no joke that is something that
could happen they I think it's like A
Clockwork Orange yeah they were talking
about neural networks early on when they
were talking about Elon was talking
about neural net that you could dampen
emotional receptors with it I think I
think that they were actually talking
about that the same we just we just put
like the neural link thing on them and
then if they ever are about to commit a
crime it just slows down their motor
functions until they stop and then the
opportunity stops and then they can only
resume if they in their mind reject the
other thing is so you'll have some dude
who wants to go out and commit crimes
and it'll start to slow down and people
go well help that man there's something
wrong I'll go try to comfort him and
then he'll reach in and take their
wallet a simple simple thing is the the
the device will start going this man is
experiencing criminal desires this man
is experiencing criminal desires and
that's like steer clear stay away stay
away stay away yeah it just broadcasts
your thoughts really loudly all the time
ever disaster that's so horrible
everyone just has their thoughts shouted
from a speaker at all times you know
what's Wild to me it's like when you're
younger and you look at criminality you
think it's like a super big deal like oh
my gosh your life is going to be over if
you commit a crime like this is insane
and then you get older and I I was um I
was actually assaulted in a grocery
store a few years ago some guy grabbed
my butt but he grabbed the wrong butt
I'll tell you right now because I sent
him straight to jail wow
um but it turns out he was on bail like
that week he had just gotten out of jail
for serial assault had grabbed four
other women in the shops that morning
none of them wanted to come to court but
I was willing to I was like yeah I'll
put forward a statement and take the
CCTV footage and everything but it's
like wild to me that he knows mere days
after getting out of jail on on bail
he's like let's go get back on the
streets
look this is another thing that often
goes unacknowledged but sex criminals
have that one of the highest rates of
recidivism if not the highest rate so
you can't just let them out on bail yeah
we got to put the neuraling thing in
them that's what I'm saying is how did
you get that guy put away what was your
process I just I called the police after
and I was like hey this happened oh and
here's another thing like a bunch of
people watched it happen and they all
just kind of froze everyone freezes when
there's something like criminal it's
like in that Starbucks
video the guy in the background just
sitting there drinking his coffee yep or
the guy on the phone being like
like y'all and I don't do it there
because where the guys you see the one
where the guy got shot on camera
don't you guys remember the Simpsons
when Mr Burns got shot by Maggie and you
just spoiled spoiler alert he explains
that like after he got shot he found
only lollygaggers and it's like Jimbo
going like whoa just like pointing at
him as he's like dying that's right
Simpson's predicted all this yeah I
don't want a society where people just
stand by and watch people get violently
assaulted but yeah like to create a
system where people are afraid to
intercede because they might become
arrested for hurting some criminal thing
this is what I was thinking I'm like no
one well first of all there were a lot
of women there uh so they don't want to
go up against a man unless they have
guns and no one has guns outside of
America
uh then there's also the fact that yeah
if you're a man and you actually win
that fight and you do the heroic thing
you're taught to do as a child you save
the woman in distress whatever goodbye
life like you're going to jail like this
dude they won't be as kind to you right
they're not gonna let you out of prison
they're going to throw the book at you
so and even if you didn't actually do
anything that rises to the level of a
crime so here's a great story that many
people in the audience May unfortunately
not have heard of Mark Houck over a year
ago was protesting outside of an
abortion clinic and he was just there
praying with his son and every time he
went there and prayed there was an older
man who would shout obscenities and
disgusting things at his son and so
finally one day this old man comes over
to him and starts approaching his son to
assault him and Mark Houck pushes the
old man away these Soros funded
prosecutor in that area said there's
nothing to charge this man with there's
literally nothing to charge this man
with there's no case here but a year
later the FBI in doj with the doj
decides to charge him the f FBI raids
his house and they try to get him
convicted with a penalty that would
result in him going to prison for 11
years for pushing a guy for pushing a
guy yeah they were saying it was a
violation of the face act and again the
Soros funded prosecutor in his area a
year earlier said there was no case
there was nothing to follow but because
he has the wrong political values
because he was protesting abortion we
should lock him up and throw away the
key take a look we have mercy for people
who are violent criminals and let them
back out onto the street to harm
everybody else we got this story from
ABC 7 grand jury could get Subway
Chokehold death of Jordan Neely case
next week so they're actually a law
enforcement Source removed investigation
tells ABC News the probe into the subway
Chokehold death is continuing the case
is likely to go to a grand jury next
week I will say this too I believe the
man's name is Daniel penny
you are going to go to prison for a very
very long time I don't know
eyewitnesses man there's a lot of
eyewitnesses that I don't think that
matters that's all that matters the
entire conversations that the
conversation that we've been having uh
is that like Kyle Rittenhouse for
instance would have would be in prison
for the rest of the life the rest of his
life if it was true that the people he
shot in self-defense were black
what we're likely going to see like with
the Ahmed Aubry case this man I think
his name is Daniel penny is likely going
to be politically convicted that's it I
mean you've got AOC calling for him to
be she's calling him a murderer she's
not even saying it's Reckless homicide
or negligence she's saying outright
that's for a jury to decide yeah exactly
you but you've got someone with 13
million followers
inciting violence in uh this is what
she's doing AOC I mean she's inciting
violence in New York City by calling
this guy a murderer and obfuscating the
facts she wants people in New York she
is like the Joker she is she is she well
more like Lex Luthor right Lex Luthor
became president that's right he did
here's an interesting thing we
discovered actually while filming
infringed is a lot of people especially
on the Progressive side of things will
look at these lower level crimes like
the mental illness assaults on uh the
subway they'll be like oh it's just like
a small thing this and that or in
Baltimore when we were filming oh they
have possession of an illegal weapon
well they didn't kill anyone they didn't
Rob anything so we're just not gonna the
progressive DA's would just be like
whatever we're not even gonna deal with
these cases they're like misdemeanors
but what occurs is when they don't deal
with those lower level cases they almost
always end up becoming more high-level
criminals it leads to murder it leads to
um you know horrible assaults horrible
robberies violence because you have to
deal with it if people start to like
test the water a bit oh I can get away
with that test the water a bit more you
can't have people getting away with
these low-level misdemeanors constantly
you can't have things like illegal
weapons carrying in Baltimore be just
like not a Quest whatsoever well this is
why giuliani's Broken Window policing
was effective you have to stop the
smaller crimes because it's not only the
case as you acknowledge that people who
commit these lower level crimes are in
some sense testing the water and seeing
what they can get away with even just
subconsciously but it's also the case
that if you know people are getting the
book thrown at them for misdemeanors
you're going to think twice about a
felony you're gonna think twice about
committing a felony
for sure I have mixed feelings about
about just just going hard to people for
Mr like drug possession marijuana well
that's just stupid laws like I don't
think like I I personally I'm okay with
Canada having marijuana legalized I
think the US should follow suit I just
think that should legalize yeah I think
it's wasted so it's wasting time it's
wasting money it's there's so much real
crime going on in this country that
could be using up the yeah but real
quick what we are seeing is that they're
legalizing drug use they're legalizing
the right to set up homeless camps in
public spaces and then they're
criminalizing self-defense that's the
problem so it's the inverse and also
when it comes to a federal War on Drugs
I oppose it I don't think there's
anything wrong with a particular State
saying we want to ban this drug or that
drug however I I don't think it's wise
as a nation to have this bizarre
two-faced halfway point where we say
this drug is illegal or X Y and Z is
illegal but it's not that serious a
crime you're not really going to get
into that much trouble if something is a
crime it should really be a crime and
that does mean we need to think twice
about what laws we have what we're
willing to ban or make illegal but once
something's not legal you really should
get in serious trouble for breaking the
law I agree with that it makes a mockery
of the judicial system or the entire CIS
legal system if you can't enforce or
don't enforce a law in the book so like
schedule one marijuana's schedule one
narcotic in the United States federally
but it's like no we're not going to
pursue it they don't they won't pursue
it it's legal in the state let me show
you this from Vivek ramaswamy in 2015
Jordan nearly Neely kidnapped a
seven-year-old girl in 2019 he punched a
64 year old man in the face in 2021 he
slugged a 67 year old woman in the face
as she exited the subway breaking her
nose and fracturing her orbital bone he
was arrested 44 times but never faced
real Justice for terrorizing New Yorkers
shares responsibility for his death for
creating an anti-law enforcement culture
you read that kidnapped a seven-year-old
kid thing and I'm just like nah I'm
sorry I'm trying well he did the
movement he Moonwalks though one time
because that makes me mad as hell and
and uh uh uh I can't play this video
no this is a video of him screaming
homophobic slurs at Joey Boots oh well
that's a real problem forget about the
kidnapping no I will I will say this
this is a video from DC Drano where he
says the video of Jordan Neely uh going
viral showing him violently assaulting a
man using homophobic slurs the f word
um I've I've not confirmed this so I
don't know that it's true but it does
look like it's him like in the video
there's a video of a guy looks just like
Nelly he's doing Michael Jackson stuff
it looks like all the other videos so I
believe it's probably correct that it is
him but I want to make sure I have that
caveat because you know take it with you
deep faces now but this is
and I know Joey Boots and there's never
a reason to have gone up you know rest
in peace Joey there was never a reason
to scream at him and threaten him
because this is not what Joey did Joey
had a video of like walking up to Tucker
Carlson he's like he's filming he walks
around New York Film oh yeah I remember
the video and Tucker is like I'm fishing
and he's like oh cool and he's like
Tucker Carlson fishing in New York and
Tucker's just like yeah and that and
then that's it Joey would do these
videos and he would go up to news
cameras and say Baba Booey Baba Booey so
when you see a video of this Neely guy
he was a violent angry dude he was mean
he attacked people he kidnapped people
how is it that this the villain the
perpetrator is what AOC and the left you
know how because this is the behavior
that they deem acceptable what this is
the behavior they deem acceptable like
mentally ill
so if a person behaves violently
in an insane way in a reckless way or
just in a flat out immoral way their
entire philosophy and the entire
philosophy of the left is the only
reason that person behaved that way is
because of certain systemic structures
that push them in that direction and so
they're not the criminal you are for not
supporting left-wing policy now that I I
understand because that is an argument
I've seen being made by people for in
that camp if there's that's what's
happening
um is that Society failed this guy flat
out he should have been either put an
institution of some sort or put in jail
after his 44th Crime After maybe it's
stealing the seven-year-old it seemed
like he wanted to go back to jail right
you know
um he probably wants to get fed three
times a day and if you're in jail that's
what you get right so because I saw
something that um I saw a tweet you know
I don't know who said it but um you know
he was saying something like uh you know
I'll go back to jail or I want to go
back to jail it's like well if there was
an asylum for somebody like this you
know he'd be taken care of he'd be off
the streets meanwhile he's homeless he's
probably hungry you'd probably save
money too in police resources constantly
dealing with these issues like sending
them to an asylum this Vancouver this is
exactly why we got the problems there
they shot I think it's Riverside there
was a massive mental Asylum and they
basically let everyone loose shut it
down I know during the Reagan Era a ton
of mental asylums were shut down as well
and it's just like boom on the streets
you think the resources that were going
into those asylums aren't going to into
police investigations solving these
issues now yeah
no oh sorry yeah go ahead well no and
this is something I touched on the show
yesterday that happened during the
Reagan Era this was also a product of
the fukuyan de-institutionalization
movement this idea on the left that
mental illness is for the most part a
social construct and we need to be more
understanding and it's true that in many
mental health facilities people were
mistreated and there was a serious
conversation that needed to be had there
however in the 1950s there were 500 000
people committed to mental institutions
across the U.S and then by the mid 80s
that falls to a hundred thousand is that
after Reagan a lot of people out or
before I I think I'm not sure at which
point the vast majority of the decrease
in those numbers occurred but I do know
that between the 1950s and the 1980s you
just have a massive
um I would say decrease in the number of
people in mental health facilities
across the country and part of that as a
result of the reclassification of what
it requires to get somebody committed so
it used to be you have to be proven to
be unable to take care of yourself and
then they change that uh standard to you
have to have been proven to be a threat
to yourself for others now often when
someone proves that they're a threat to
themselves or others it's too late
someone's already been hurt so I don't
know if the standard should be they
can't take care of themselves as it used
to be but I think the standard we have
now clearly isn't working it looks like
it was 81. the when Reagan's ended the
mental health systems Act of 1980. he
like right when he got it off is that
true in California I think as well he
signed a bill I think the lantris
Peterson yeah that's 1967 that he did
that yeah
did you know this sorry random
interesting fact there's so many Reagan
facts I learned while doing the infringe
stuff he was one of the first people to
pass one of the mass gun control acts as
Governor yeah Reagan was not was
certainly far from perfect like everyone
Praises him because of the way he stood
up to Communism and I think that that
was great I think that was great I will
not take that from him however he was
certainly not the best president in
America he had a lot of great one-liners
though I think that's right
he like doubled the amount of federal
employees though while standing against
communism
imagine most of that was uh military
position no it was like pencil push
paper pushers whatever there's a lot of
those in the military though that he was
like really didn't like George we're
senior sorry does that need a corkscrew
yeah I was gonna ask if you could open
this there's a corkscrew running out of
else Tim don't open it for her she's
gonna put dog I saw that she opened it
but then she didn't do it she's gonna
put Diet Coke in it and it's a 25 year
old scotch
good good
slow process from here all right in case
you're listening I'm such an expensive
booze and it just breaks when I twist it
lightly because people like you who
don't know what they're doing are going
to ruin it and so they intentionally
design it it's like child proofing but
for people who put Diet Coke in their
alcohol
now what Reagan uh cuddle Ronald I heard
that Reagan hated George wouldn't let me
but I hate it but really didn't like
George Bush Senior really at all they
were I think they ran against each other
if I'm from the priorities
and then like what the Deep State went
to him and was like you're gonna have
imagination attempt and then after that
he made him his VP I mean I don't know
if that's true but I've heard that story
yeah so this Reagan guy I mean was he
one of those guys who's like going in
with all the righteousness and then as
soon as he gets in there like here's
your talking here's your Playbook by the
way and he's like uh I don't think so
then bang bang and then he's like okay
I'll play ball well this is what's crazy
is even when he wasn't because you know
I was getting in a debate with my dad
about this lovey dad
um and we were talking about Reagan and
gun control and he's like oh you know he
was more Democrat early on he probably
changed his mind and I'm like yeah you
know he did a lot of good things in
government but actually even when he was
out of office he wrote into
um wrote to lawmakers supporting the
assault weapons ban that Biden passed
saying I support this put this through
and that was after yeah
and he was out of office right and
that's what we have to remember firstly
Reagan said something it's quite a
famous quote and this is something that
many people who are considered Centrist
or you know 2010 era liberals say today
what Reagan said was I am considered
conservative just for holding to the
liberal principles that I had 20 years
ago something along those lines Reagan
was not the far right conservative that
the left made him out to be because we
should understand that no fault divorce
well because look at it I mean everyone
thinks Reagan was this far a
conservative president okay well they
call Tim pool far right today so of
course in the 80s when they were calling
yeah when they were calling Reagan far
right that didn't mean anything then
either wow I wanna I wanna I wanna jump
to the story and I I do feel kind of bad
because we're talking about communism
stuff but this is important breaking
news check this out Vice media nears
deal for 400 million dollars sale out of
bankruptcy
Fortress investment and Soros fund
management come on here's the here's
here's the funniest thing about this
right it's the deal gives them an
evaluation around 400 million a major
drop from 5.7 billion here's the other
thing though the evaluation includes the
existing debt that it has how much the
debt I believe there was a 250 million
dollar debt financing around a few years
ago and then a 30 million I'm not
exactly sure how they're how they're
doing it the 250 million in debt was
from Soros I think that was Soros fund
management as well
so it may be that source is actually
just buying the company for what would
that give them 120 million dollars no no
220 million dollars
from a company that was once once worth
5.7 billion so of the 400 million
they're paying out 220 of it was debt so
Soros already has 250 million in debt
with Vice so if the deal is for 400
million which includes the debt I could
be wrong about this maybe building check
could could clarify if someone who knows
how the economics works of it but it
sounds like Soros already holds a
portion of that 400 million unless the
deal is to buy out the rest of it but
then he holds the debt so I think this
multi-billion dollar company is being
washed out for a couple hundred million
the whole click bait apparatus is dying
people are sick of it buzzfeed's gone
and it's only being upheld by political
actors like but but Vice wasn't that in
the beginning
Vice got big because they were like
we're gonna go down and we're gonna hunt
down Scopolamine yeah dude
the magic Shaman who's gonna do crazy
like Ayahuasca and then it turned into
10 reasons SpongeBob's homophobic what
happened do you remember how do you know
how it changed exactly was there a
linchpin that switched or was it just a
slow burn Tim left I was told that was
it I was going I was I was there when
they were doing the based so so actually
Vice news started because of me and that
is the words of Shane Smith he said at
the night Foundation Awards they were
doing on the ground reporting but it was
not there was no news division they were
doing these like Adventure style
documentary shows where it's about the
regular guy going to Afghanistan and
telling a story and then I I was like I
want to do real news reporting what
changed simply is
in from my perspective I agree with this
take but this came from a friend of mine
who is who is a high level employee
they got accused of sexual harassment
and assault
and to get out of it the investors were
like become a feminist company that way
you can get past the negative press the
concern was it like we're not going to
go down and see our hundreds of millions
of dollars in investment lost
so just come out start doing feminist
stuff and you'll be safe from these
attacks and they went you got it talk
about a fall from grace if they went the
route I explained in my vision they
would be worth still billions of dollars
I told them to go the route that we are
going here yeah maybe they would be
worth like 900 million or 1.3 billion
like a quarter of what they ended up at
what they were at one point but they'd
still be around no I don't believe any
of what you guys are saying you think
I'm a liar I think both of you I think
what happened was Tim told them Tim saw
what the future was and he said you know
what you guys should do you should
Pander to feminists and the left the
young people love it you're going to get
a lot of viewership it's what the
mainstream media is doing let's imitate
the big guys because you wanted to leave
and start your own thing and then you
did I went and worked for Disney you
neutered them you wanted a little more
experience before you got out you know
and did your own thing you were you
played the long con the same thing
happened with fusion and it was
hilarious when I went to Fusion which is
ABC News Univision they said we want to
be nice Vice we want to be young young
and edgy but we don't want to do the
weird stuff where they like crap in jugs
and like throw it in the air or
something like that because Vice did
like weird stuff like that and then I
was like cool and they said we want to
do a show that's very much travel
Adventure meeting like drug dealers in
Venezuela and covering those stories and
I'm like perfect let's make it happen
and then eight months later they brought
in a new editor-in-chief who changed his
Twitter Banner to down with whiteness
and then I was like oh boy and then I
was just like I was like here's what
here's my plan for this November I'm
gonna go to Fukushima on the anniversary
and or or you know and see where they're
at with the like the re the
Redevelopment of the region and then
they were like okay that's cool I guess
it gets half a million views over the
weekend and then they're like but we're
still really interested in talking about
trans kids which gets like a thousand
views they were obsessed with chasing
the stuff sure enough a couple years
later they lay off everybody and they
washed billions down the toilet did
Shane leave the company at some point no
he's still there so he's getting this
he's not the CEO anymore and they're
saying they're gonna find a role for him
but like this guy's just not worth
anything anymore more I mean look I Got
Me Wrong the dude's probably worth you
know I don't know what this puts puts
him at maybe
um Shane Smith yeah that'll put him at
maybe 80 million which is like like come
on it's not nothing he's a rich guy but
to have been a billionaire like the
media reporting you're worth 2 billion
or whatever and now it's just like yeah
you know I don't think they're complete
idiots for marketing to the woke crowd
like I do think there is a large I'm not
on some copium or I think the majority
of the population are conservatives I've
I'm from Canada so I'm like okay there
are actually a lot of woke people out
there but it's just very hard to sell
wokeness through a corporation
through these like they can see the even
even the very silly kind of brainwashed
people they're like okay this is
clickbait this is a corporation that
makes millions of dollars telling me
about how we need to support trans
impoverished individuals doing ketamine
like that they can see the absurdity
itself it's I don't know there is there
is a craving in general for more genuine
I think that's why live streaming has
become more a bigger thing in general
even the left-wing live streamers on
Twitch and stuff uh people are just
getting real tired of the highly curated
actual
um full-on propaganda it's just like the
Internet is just full-on MK Ultra yeah
all corporations are not people and when
they say stuff like Disney says that
something no no Disney isn't a thing
that can speak Disney's just a facade a
piece a paper that you tear away to see
who was it that said that yeah like if
you want to make the argument that
corporations are people then I'd love to
see some of these corporations go to
prison so when
so yes so when like a big pharmaceutical
company for instance is accused of fraud
we don't simply Go pass a fine we say we
are going to incarcerate your
corporation for five years meaning it
cannot operate everybody who works there
you no longer work there come back in
five years and let's see where you're at
and they go well we couldn't do that it
would be bad for the economy well tell
that to the guy who went to prison for
five years what's he supposed to do when
he gets out sorry I don't play that if
you've got a corporation and there are
people breaking the law within it and
it's widespread and the whole company
does it shut it down or even like 30 for
the death penalty in that case too oh
like the execution of the corporation
over the company Erasure of the machine
yeah I think that if you sell a company
you guys should change the name that's
that's I think unethical to call it
something else because a company is
amazing though but it's the company is
the people that are in the company that
is what it is it's a company of people
and so if the people change then it's a
different company so yeah but I mean
look I don't want the factory I just
want the name Callahan it's a premium
then have it in parentheses behind the
new name at least so you see the trail
of like what it used to be what Disney
now is but it's not Disney Walt Disney's
gone that's going to make for very long
domain names yeah and and the
corporation owns a bunch of Ip so uh
you're talking about branding like a
Rebrand if they want it's like black
water they just reappear right something
new every other year
the idea that you could go to a say a
major pharmaceutical like let's say
there's a major pharmaceutical that was
accused of Fraud and then found to be
liable for that fraud and we're fined
billions I can't think of anything like
that I'm pretty sure it's all of them
every single one like we just it's a
cost of doing business so now you have
these big Pharmaceuticals being like
okay how much money can we make off
defrauding people 2 billion what will we
find by the government 1 billion hot dog
we're gonna make a million a billion
dollars that's what they do there needs
to be a more serious policy does anyone
have the schizophrenic soap Bonners soap
where it's got like all oh yes that
spies on you why is it schizo so no it's
it's got like so much text about like
religion and God and you just sit there
and read it it's the one true religion
the Dr Bonner broners anyways disagree
disagree well no it's yeah I don't even
know what uh we should talk about the
True Religion guys I love Dr Bronner so
anyways my point is they should have
that on any sort of pharmaceutical
company's bottle but it's like all of
their lawsuits no it's just listed all
over it and that should be their
punishment you have to list all it's
available if you buy a pack of
cigarettes it has like a limp dick on it
or something right it's kind of like
that especially the last decade of
lawsuits yeah how much money they wash
off after time yeah you know what you
know what I think would actually be even
better than that for political campaigns
at the end of a political ad in the same
way that pharmaceutical ads have to list
side effects they have to list every
Scandal that politician is involved in
and like every policy failure yeah it's
Christian
Contra Scandal yeah yeah every stock
like all of it that was an extremely
based bill of Matt Gates and AOC to
support oh yeah it was Wild Bill against
insider trading I love seeing that I
love seeing the far left and the far
right come together to own politicians
you know I do appreciate it you know
what the bills is insane and wrong and
yeah not wrong on this but she's not
wrong on this don't you dare attack my
queen
your queen your favorite is true behind
the scenes this is behind the scenes
Lauren gush is about AOC non-stop it's
called the restoring faith and
Government Act I like the name restoring
my faith in AOC act yeah I think you're
onto something with AOC like it's it's
not it's not time to demonize it exactly
like if you really think she's Lex
Luthor has that kind of power to become
Lex Luthor we should engage in
conversation now and get ahead of this
and rather than just wait for some
horrible populist Uprising where we use
the mob to dictate Law and Order I think
we need to psychologically manipulate
her by whenever she does anything like
really good super red pill right wing
need to just send her like super loving
messages constantly and just be like
keep going Queen keep going and then
she'll slowly like psychologically be
like oh well I'm getting a lot of
support for this and just move further
and further right and then until I fixed
her and then everyone's Gonna Keep
criticizing her from the right when she
does something bad and then it's just
going to be psychological abuse
very brutal both but both ways gonna be
like insanely High Praise and then
really brutal criticism
is is a hardcore manipulation right now
but like this is a narcissistic cycle
to be like we love you so much but I
can't believe you've failed us here
we're really disappointed but we believe
in you oh my gosh wouldn't it be awesome
if political commentary was done that
way you're like I don't know if you guys
sorry go ahead I gotta give a shout out
to pinochet's helicopter tours who says
Tim I caught the Tommy Boy quote
everyone missed thank you sir what was
it when I said I don't want the factory
I just want Callahan it's a premium name
premium name yeah Tommy Boy come on
great movie yeah that would be David you
guys uncultured uncultured no that's
true the Pinnacle of culture was
Saturday Night Live ever actually good
or yeah I honestly wonder about Mike
Myers Dana
carveyors hold on hold on in the very
beginning I hear I wasn't around for it
there were definitely talented people
there and there were some good skits but
we also have a selection bias you always
end up seeing the best stuff from that
era so I wonder if overall it was
actually they developed Wayne's World on
SNL like it was Sandman Adam Sandler uh
Rob Schneider it was just an incredible
incredible group man incredible and
Robin Schneider third has all those
movies where he turns into random things
yeah those are Classics those are
classic all the movie spin-offs I think
the Congressional library has selected
those pressure Kevin Nealon oh man Kevin
Nealon's new when he did the news it was
so Deadpool Norm Macdonald was in there
so yeah no look look like I said I will
not deny that there are talented people
there and I'm not even necessarily
saying they weren't ever great I'm just
saying I wonder how great they were
because I wasn't watching it back then
and the only footage I see from it is
likely the best stuff and there wasn't
much else on like now we've got 10 000
more things that we can compare with
late night comedy too that's also true
we just did normal World shout out to
Dave Landau quarter black Garrett with
the blaze I was on the new one so you're
going to want to go to drug Topia on
YouTube and check out normward but
people are saying it's like SNL how was
in the 80s later oh that's awesome I
think that's awesome brilliant genius uh
Community he always yeah yeah he always
got a laugh out of me
me too yeah he's a funny guy yeah Dave
come back are you me too in Dave Landon
that's right you're Union what happened
when you were out there
are you having trouble opening a bottle
of soda this is the second bottle you
have struggled to open on this show I
gotta go to the bathroom this is thanks
for letting us know I swear Lauren if
you mix that I'm mixing the Glenlivet
that's disgusting it's like Lauren this
is the show
and whiskey Aficionado she's a whiskey
iconoclast if anything gets you canceled
it has to be this I'm a Trailblazer
that's you know when I got five-year-old
scotch and you just put Diet Coke in it
I'm a trailer I'm sure it's fine when I
got banned from the UK for my uh allies
gay thing they started a gay Muslim
Pride Parade like four years later
that's so weird they Banned Me from the
country then this is going to be the
trend I actually I think I think we're
going to say at some point there's a
bridge too far
oh don't act like you're enjoying that
don't act like that is it actually good
I imagine no would you like it
there's a Diet Coke I wouldn't want to
be honest like I don't mind the alcohol
even though I know it's bad it's like
the aspartame in the diet yeah exactly
yeah
the alcohol I know it's bad but the
aspartame freaks me out so I don't know
if you guys know about this but uh so
I've got a friend uh who's from India
and um he uh he tells me that with AOC
there's like a a power behind the throne
kind of a figure who's from India as
well
and I forget his name now
um but uh you know apparently this guy
uh you know he he found her in like a
bar you know because she was a bartender
and uh you know because he was looking
for somebody to be like the figurehead
of you know this you know new popular
politician you know for the left and uh
basically developed her into what she is
today and all this stuff so I don't know
if this is you know I I I've just never
heard it before he sent me an article
about it but I can't find it now I just
thought if maybe one of you guys knew
about that I'm sure it's less nefarious
than it sounds I think she's just a bad
person you know yeah but it's like she's
not like a simple solution
have you guys watched the boys yeah you
know the AOC character she like explodes
people's heads yeah is that the right
one yeah yeah I never I never I know
it's an excellent show and it is
completely true to all politics yeah but
they document they do the scene at the
end where homelander he's basically
Superman and a Donald Trump which is
really hilarious he's a very funny I
know he he he kills a a protester and
then all of the Maga people cheer for it
I'm kind of like nah the only problem is
but I think it could it just applies to
politics in general as well as the left
but it's obviously got this like
hyperbolic dude I'm pretty sure
Stormfront was intended to be Laura
Loomer
I'm not kidding that's a dark-haired
girl Stormfront is a woman who is like
an actual Nazi who's Immortal or
something like that and then she's
pretending to not be a Nazi but is
secretly a Nazi and I'm like I think
they're trying they're they're trying to
directly like it's it's a left-wing bias
super like fantasy world where they're
drawing correlations between reality but
from a weird left-wing view like
homelander is Superman but he's also
Donald Trump it's kind of a weird thing
to say I just think the same plotline
can apply to any like left-wing politics
they just of course because it's media
and Hollywood they have to do it from an
anti-right perspective but it's
anti-right but they're also saying Trump
is Superman yeah you know
have you considered that I mean white
man with a lot of power it sounds like
fascism to me that there is there are
story lines in the comic book about
Superman becoming a tyrant yeah exactly
yeah I mean he wouldn't he immediately
well remember remember what was his name
Phoenix Jones yes real dude in Seattle
right walking around and like and the
left time the left he was a real he
probably still exists or maybe not
considering what's going on in Seattle
but uh he was the real life vigilante
superhero who would dress up in an
outfit he had a group with him too he
had a group for her group and then when
the antifa Right started he was with the
cops so they're like you're a fascist
because you're helping police Benjamin
he's like John Francis these people are
destroying the city like I don't get it
you're the bad guys I'm like no you're
the bad guy you're helping cops and they
would have they would carry like a film
crew around or dudes would be on their
cameras recording so he gained
popularity there was a Batman in uh
Toronto as well a few years ago but but
he would just go around in a Batman
costume and sneak up behind people and
go where are
Wikipedia says he was a real life
superhero but I'm like no he wasn't he
was a vigilante like yes super
superheroes
it implies you have powers of some sort
this is a guy wearing a costume who's
the closest thing we've had to like a
real life Batman Temple no no you gotta
do you know that's true well you can't
tell people the simping is next level
there really isn't anybody Clark Kent
and I tweeted at Elon Musk I was like
why haven't you bought an Iron Man suit
yet and he said building Starship and I
was like okay that's fair you know like
is it though yeah he's building a ship
to colonize other planets it's the wrong
genre it's uh sci-fi and not you know
superhero but okay well I'll give them a
pass on that one if you think about it
he's doing something you know I mean in
the realm of psychology because like we
don't actually have people that go out
and punch dudes and drag them around but
like psychological Batman Tim's a pretty
good candidate hold on I got it I Gotta
Give it I gotta give a shout out to Noah
Sanders who says SNL was was funny when
Norm Macdonald was on it yes Norm
Macdonald did that Bill Clinton remember
was on The View and he was like killed
somebody and they're like stop saying
that and he was like I thought this was
a common knowledge yeah
question Sheamus who's your favorite
superhero oh that's a good question I I
guess I haven't thought about it that
much uh I mean Abraham favorite
superhero movies I loved the uh I loved
the Dark Knight you know when that came
out he just wants to do the voice Bane
is my favorite too Sheamus
you're with hearing the darkness is your
ally
um yeah I think probably probably Batman
but that's kind of a tough one I just
like those films I haven't given it that
much thought what about you
oh geez I like to Gambit for a long time
he's an X-Man oh man my favorite
superhero that's wild
Nightcrawler he's pretty cool oh is he
wait who's the one who's Catholic is
that Nightcrawler I don't think so he's
a German dude with blue skin he's like
got a tail and he can teleport hold on I
love it he's not Catholic I'm pretty
sure he's Catholic he's Catholic I think
so all right you know what night crawler
is actually my favorite super right now
you know because of my identity Politics
the teleportation ability is really cool
that's like one of my favorite superhero
what about you Lord superhero ah what's
what's the blue girl who can turn into
stuff Marvel nerds seething yeah that's
mixing Scotch with Coke from uh yeah
midnight
it was played her I got bad news guys
what Phoenix Jones was arrested January
2020 for allegedly selling methyl I
can't say this MDMA how do you say it
methylene methylene methylene dioxy
methamphetamine to an undercover police
officer how the mighty have fallen oh
John that's kind of wild that like you'd
think superhero becomes
Batman broke bad but instead of like
trying to take over Gotham he's like all
right I got your myth for you now you're
selling MDMA you're saving that police
officer's mental health okay it's
Mystique Mystique yes she can change
forms I don't like her I think that
would be a cool superpower that's that's
my question
a good superpower okay so I feel like
it's almost childish to say Superman but
100 I mean he's op but I think I'd take
Superman's power what about what about
like Jean Gray who that I only say Jean
Gray because Professor X can't walk
she's one so it's like you'd rather have
telekinesis and telepathy but have the
ability to walk and fly too you know
like Jean Gray and you know you'd want
telepathy
I'm asking oh okay yeah yeah because
Professor X can control people's minds
you know well like Superman can like
Superman even travels back in time
sometimes it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous he doesn't have the power to
the flash can do it because he has speed
force and all that and speed force its
own thing that makes no sense but like
it's speed force flash can also kidnap
indigenous women really quickly has he
done that before yeah
Who's acting him
right right right
I think in court they need to do a
forensic analysis of that moonwalking on
the sideways
oh my Bonkers yeah can we pull that up
they're brutal I don't know very funny
who's your favorite superhero
superheroes it's it's all nettle and
propaganda man go deeper so true king
Nephilim like the ancient from the Bible
the ancient ones right yeah yeah uh you
know it's half human half angel or or
half God right A lot of these
superheroes are like that right they got
special powers they're like gods to the
people
and uh yeah it's just Nephilim
propaganda man so you know we all need
to repent from that do you think the
Nephilim were real I do yes I think
they're real today James do you think
they're real so Nephilim is there's this
little moment in Genesis 6 I believe
where there's a mention of the Nephilim
and it's something like that the
children of God saw the daughters of men
but
there have been so many different
interpretations extrapolated out of it I
have two main ones yeah I can't make
heads or Tales of exactly what that
verse means I the Jimmy Aiken did a very
interesting analysis of it a little
while back that I thought was super
helpful but I'll never forget doing a uh
but we don't one thing is I know when
the sons of God came in unto the
daughters of men I know what that is but
but
I've heard some people say that well
like regionally there was a group of
people who were very powerful who they
referred to at that language it's it's
there's two can I believe just that
there are people out there with
superpowers you know can you just let me
have that I won't tell you that you
can't I I don't know maybe some people
can do things that I'm not aware of but
are they bad are they evil I think so
yeah well yeah I think the general uh
sense is that they're they're bad we're
bad uh well that's that's usually how
it's described again I can't speak on it
too much because there's just this one
short version It's Genesis
so yeah um there's two main views one is
that it's the uh the line of Seth and
the line of Cain so you know they're all
humans uh it doesn't really uh follow it
doesn't follow logic basically because
it's like well you know
um
I should I should actually read it now
but um the the other line or the other
view is is called the Angel View which
is that the sons of God
which is uh in Hebrew the banay hiloim
sons of God that that term is this is is
used in the Old Testament uh to
basically describe a a direct creation
by God so Adam was a benign a son of God
and then um you know and and later on in
in the Old Testament as well you uh the
same term is used you know in terms of
angels right
um
uh most most human beings so post Adam
would be described as son of man
right so uh when it says in Genesis 6
the sons of God it's most likely it
talks about angels so they came down and
and in The Book of Enoch which is not in
the Bible it it basically says that much
more clearly which is also like a really
old book right it's it's uh it's a
well-regarded book it's not canon but
it's highly regarded and um in in that
book also uh the sons of God is you know
it's talking about angels so they came
down well it's in the Book of Enoch
where the dude goes up to heaven or
something yeah yeah yeah I think that
with oh I'm sorry I want to let you
continue because I think yeah yeah so
yeah basically it so um yeah so they
came down they they had sex with human
women and they and and they birthed
hybrid beings
uh who uh it seems like we're Giants
it's not exactly true that they were
giants but it seems like they were
because later on in the scripture you
read about Giants as well oh sorry this
is what I wanted to comment on
congratulations because I was doing a
uniform yes okay okay it's about the
Nephilim because I don't want to move
from this before no don't worry um I was
doing a university course on city of God
by Saint Augustine a few years okay
based right uh directed study and then
we get to a part of the book where Saint
Augustine is talking about seeing a
giant skull on the beach and like giant
bones and stuff and I'm like hello like
class like has anyone else seen this and
they're just like no no that's not the
point Lauren moving on and I'm like what
we're not gonna talk
the myth of Giants and cyclops likely
came from elephant skulls yeah and they
thought the trunk hole was an eye hole
yeah I've heard that so I know that so
for example the Catholic Church doesn't
have an official teaching on like with
the nephilimore I know a lot of people
argue that they're the sons of God could
translate to like demons or Fallen
Angels that's been widely speculated but
then part of the difficulty there is
that Angels don't have bodies right they
can't procreate the way people do and uh
and I know that I and I just found this
information I want to address that
everybody thing before you move on
aren't they like big wheels or something
like so there's different experience
classes yeah yeah there's there's
differences there is one that's
described as like a big wheel with wings
but I I just want to finish I found it I
found a very um this could be helpful I
found a very interesting little bit here
on Catholic answers from Tom Nash and he
just wrote a pretty lengthy thing on
this but one part I want to Zone in on
because he's referencing the church
fathers is is that he writes the early
church fathers generally understood the
sons of God to be The Offspring of Seth
the righteous son of Adam where his
daughters of men are understood to be
The Offspring of Cain the immoral son of
Adam thus fallen once could be
understood as the fruit of succumbing to
the corrupt Canaanite culture which is
an interesting interpretation
I haven't looked at it myself but I've
heard that a lot of early church fathers
actually believe the Angel View so I
don't know when when the thing came into
play but well yeah and like I said the
Nephilim thing has always been uh
it's always been interesting every time
it's come up I haven't done a deep dive
into it and part of it is I there is no
like official Catholic stance on it and
but it's it's it's be part of why it's
so tantalizing is because so little is
written about it right it just comes up
there for a moment of the Bible and then
it's not talked about again later so
people are naturally going to read
things into that and try to extrapolate
I think it's an important issue because
um why was the flood sent right it you
know it says explicitly because of the
the you know a man man's violence on the
earth and that sort of thing right all
man was corrupt no but if you read a
little deeper
um if it's true that you know that these
were Fallen Angels who came down and
made it with human women right
um that that's a Corruption of of the
human genome okay now in Genesis 3 this
is right after the fall and and God you
know
God went to confront
um
um them in the garden after the fall you
know what did you do and then he
basically tells uh he tells a serpent
that um I'm I'm going to put war between
you and the woman see the seed of the
woman which is a very odd phrase because
a woman doesn't have seed right
that's a prophecy of Jesus Christ the
seed of the woman virgin birth right I'm
going to put I'm going to put a war
between you two so right away there's
already like
um if you're Satan you know okay uh his
plan is is to have
um is
is to basically bring about a human a
human Redeemer right so this is this is
this is the Incarnation of Jesus Christ
in the flesh to be the offering for you
know on the sin of men how to be a human
being right
um so
what's his plan after that if you're
Satan you you want to corrupt the DNA of
mankind right so it got so bad it was so
successful that that's why the flood was
sent to basically wipe this out because
it talks about Noah Noah Noah was uh
perfect in his Generations
what does that mean
Noah was perfect in his gym well I I
would disagree because I don't believe
that Satan's interest is in corrupting
human genetics it's incorrupting man's
heart because that's what God wants
God's not interested in our genes no DNA
is very it's a very important part of
redemption I think because I disagree I
think that's it I mean that's the term
view of it right that's a very ancient
Jewish view of it because they were
chosen Redeemer the term Kinsmen or
demon uh Kinsmen Redeemer why why why
that word Kinsmen it means you know when
you talk of somebody's kin you talk of
somebody's relative right and we're part
of the human family made in the image of
God there are other beings out there
like angels and different classes of
angels they do not qualify for you know
for the work of the cross
right wait repeat that so that wait who
doesn't qualify for the world
but but angels for sure like angels
angels are not human beings though right
so I'm saying there aren't specific
kinds of human beings of whom we could
say they don't have the right genetic
combination in order to be sick the
devil is not trying to alter but also
there's other elements here that are
there are other elements here that are
important well no Angels don't have DNA
because they're not they're not physical
beings uh and also there are angels I
mean there are there are ancient Jewish
commentaries that offer up reasons for
why the flood happened one of which
being that it's because men were
entering into contracts with other men
mm-hmm
who came down to who came down to visit
a lot
and and do you talk about the Angels
you're talking about okay yeah sure
when the men of Sodom and Gomorrah saw
them they wanted to rape them yeah okay
but they're men but they're also Angels
well but that doesn't mean they
literally have physical form it means
they're appearing in such a way so that
they can communicate with the human
beings in that area probably
hyperdimensionality they you know they
can probably materialize
flying machines with light on them maybe
maybe one way to explain it would be
like imagine if on this table there's
like little tiny houses and stuff and we
are looking down at these little tiny
people and then you put your hand down
and walk with your hand like it's a
person yeah like it's not a real person
um I think that's a good rough two
angels went uh to visit Abraham as well
right and Sarah
now let's do the hand puppet thing where
it's like we're looking down in these
little little creatures and we stick our
hand in there and like pick oh yeah like
shining a spotlight on the ground and
moving it around if you're in a hot air
balloon with a spotlight yeah so I I
think there's also like talking about
other dimensionalities that we're kind
of thing yeah there's there's another
one we're in a separate Dimension and
they're only putting the tip of their
finger in to interact with them so this
leads in well can I can I just wait yeah
I just want to respond to your point so
eating uh just in a very human sense and
also in terms of how it's often
expressed biblically it's a way of
relating to other people right people
sit down and they eat with one another
so I think that Angels either creating
some kind of Illusion of a physical form
where they're eating communicates a kind
of community or agreement with that
person and it doesn't necessarily say we
have DNA right right and I agree because
I've seen Cookie Monster eat but he's
not really eating it's just flapping
them out cookies go flying all around
right exactly but like I don't think
it'd look like that no but but you know
my point Cookie Monster doesn't have DNA
yeah dogs
have DNA right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
he became flesh but what what kind of
Flesh did he become he became yeah the
god became man but man not dog not Angel
you know say they have DNA okay he did
not become Angel because there were
Angels who sinned right yeah the Fallen
Angels yeah you know this uh in II Peter
I think he says that as well uh you know
those who who did not keep their first
estate so these are angels who came down
and committed sin so there are there are
angels who have sinned they have no
chance of redemption okay
and Bartleby and Dogma they have no
chance because Jesus Christ became a man
and he died for the sins of man so if
you're an angel who has sinned you're
out of luck right you cannot be redeemed
through that what about Dogma remember I
have not seen it nope so Loki and
Bartleby are fallen angels and then
there's a centennial at a church and
they say that all those who walk through
the the gates during the Centennial will
have their sins forgiven and then Loki
is like this is how we get into heaven
and Loki's like what someone's Church
doesn't mean we can and it was like what
you hold true on Earth I will hold true
in heaven we will be forgiven and we can
go home and that's the premise of the
movie well it's the gospel of that movie
I guess but it's interesting to think
that a non-human could be Redeemed by a
human God maybe that's true well because
God well no in the Incarnation he
stooped down to our level in a sense
there's a I've heard it expressed that
way but
God is obviously is outside of spaces
outside of time through the Incarnation
God did become man but my understanding
and part of the Catholic understanding
of what's different between human and
angels and part of why that Redemption
doesn't apply is firstly of course God
behaves in mysterious ways we can't
always explain or understand why he
would choose for his Redemption to be
efficacious
not for the Angels but one explanation
I've heard that I think is pretty uh
compelling is because angels have the
capability of acting with will in a way
that's uh not as pronounced in human
beings because we're less intelligent
than they are so because of their
Superior intellect they're more capable
and because they don't have physical
bodies and aren't uh in time the exact
same way we are their choice is
permanent whenever they make one so it's
not just that they can't be forgiven God
does not expect much of us well they
can't repent well God I think there's an
argument to be made that he respects
less of us than he or expects less of us
in a certain sense because of our
corporeal form and limitations than he
would expect of angels because we are
different beings
we were made in the image of God and
angels were not we were very special
we're made in God's image and likeness
yeah like we're made in God's image
that's a big deal no disagree Angels
yeah they they don't have that
distinction yeah that's an interesting
point so maybe Adam did have Superior
intellect before the fall before you're
arguing that's interesting I'd have to
consider that I've never heard that I'd
have to think about that and read about
that and he also knew what he was doing
by the way he was not deceived right it
was Eva was deceived by the way I just
want to throw that out there as well
because yeah it does describe I agree
that it will will knowing the right
answer and choosing to do wrong is much
more sinful than not knowing and doing
the wrong thing well there's a there's
there's increased levels of culpability
based on your level of knowledge and
ability this is true so you know
basically what you're saying there too
uh
um so with Adam uh he knew exactly what
what he was doing when when you know he
he basically
um so he loved his wife so much that
when she ate of the fruit
and fell into sin that he would he did
not want to lose her that this is what I
think I I actually agree with that he
did not want to lose her and so he he
also willingly partook of the fruit and
willingly disobeyed to be with his wife
because he loved her so much that that
that's that's reflection of Jesus Christ
in the church
because he willingly died as well so he
could be with his church so the bride of
Christ can I can I comment because I
agree with part of that and disagree
with the other part of it it's it's
definitely been a part of ancient
commentary and there's a theological
basis for saying one of the reasons Adam
did choose to eat of the fruit was
because he did not want to be separated
from his wife uh however I know that the
church and myself don't understand that
to mean that that it was a good thing
and that that was an act of love because
by committing that whereas Christ's
death for us was an act of love and was
a good thing but there's more to it than
that I've mentioned this on the show
before too uh Adam sinned in the sense
also that he saw his wife talking to a
snake and didn't intervene and there's a
reason the serpent went for Eve there's
a reason sir the servant for Eve because
the man is supposed to engage in
discourse for the household and so part
of the result of that is that women tend
in their fallen nature because all
humans have a fallen nature towards
usurpation and trying to take roles that
are meant for men and men fail in the
sense that we abdicate our
responsibility and don't do what's
necessary to protect women it's also
possible because I think when when when
God when God told Adam you you can't eat
from this fruit that was before Eve was
was made I think right so I think he
told both of them so uh yeah I I'm not
clear on that so that that's just what
I'm thinking do you think that Adam did
the right thing by joining his wife in
the tripping balls or whatever the hell
they were that's tough I mean it's tough
it's tough to say because I mean uh on
on the face of it no it was the wrong
thing he he said he's right he disobeyed
God but again you know it's like
you know the lamb uh was slain before
the foundation of the world so God knew
this would happen at the same time so
it's like it's one of those things where
I'm like yeah I'm not sure like it was
it was part of the plan or not also when
the serpent comes to Eve he says is it
not true that you can't eat of any of
the trees and she said well no we can't
eat from that tree so she did know she
didn't know also I find that why she
told by Adam or was she told you I
believe she's told I'd have to double
check yeah yeah I guess anyways it's not
a big yeah yeah but it's interesting I
love how before I think because also she
was not Fallen though right she was not
fallen so she would have been in Greater
contact with God than people are no
regardless no yeah yeah yeah you were
literally like this is gonna become a
Bible study isn't it see this is the
metaphor I can think of is like if my
wife was smoking weed and I'm like man
when you get high I can't get through to
you like this so maybe I'll smoke weed
with you like that's like Adam maybe
eating the fruit to be with this woman
maybe it was just a big old simp you
know well that is but that is well this
is one of the things in in uh different
theologians have described this
differently but basically Adam and Eve
they committed different sins and father
Ripper talks about this and I believe
the way he broke it down was I think
Adam committing seven sins and Eve
committing five and I can't remember
exactly how he explained them but one of
the sins of Adam was basically what we
would colloquially refer to as being a
simp he chose the woman over God and in
doing so he wasn't actually choosing
what was good for her right because you
can't choose the best thing for another
person if unless you're choosing what
God wants you to choose oh man that's
tough I think there's something
successful in itself of going back in
time and being like all women are
responsible or all men are responsible
for this everyone's trying to abdicate
their own responsibility for original
sin and sin in general you had a great
tweet the other day that was like stop
purity testing others and start purity
testing yourself amen why why yeah
exactly uh why not remove the beam from
your own eyes are you saying that Rose
before hoes is codified in the Bible
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is uh obey God love the Lord your
God with all your heart but that's a bit
different he broke the bros before hose
rule that's what this mess now you could
ask what's more important you know
adhering to God's will or being with
your wife well well but but actually
God's will I don't know
I guess God is like I gave you all like
imagine you know you hook up a guy and
his wife with a place to live and food
and that they're they're in need and
you're like I got you this place you can
crash in my place there's beers in the
fridge there's pizzas and just just
don't eat my apples dude like I I really
like there's a psilocybin in there no no
it's just they're mine you can have
anything from the fridge you don't gotta
worry about rent just please don't eat
my apples and then Eve's like I'm gonna
eat one and then he's like okay I guess
like that's a dick move you know what I
mean yeah well also I mean God told them
not to do this one thing that's
fascinating I know that uh and I'm
blanking on his name but there's an old
um
Orthodox Theologian who said that God
may have allowed them to eat from that
tree later but didn't think that they
were ready I don't know if that's the
official position of the church I just
find that to be an interesting
commentary from an orthodox Theologian
I'm just like simply put if if someone
is letting you stay at their place and
it's like everything well God told them
not to so okay
and what did the devil say you will be
become like Gods if you do it he told
them the same lie that people tell
themselves and that he tells people
today you will become your own God you
will become like God but the snake is
like the neighbor who comes over it's
like eat the apple who cares screw this
guy she's like all right so many people
treat it like a a cruelty like he was
trying to prevent them from some sort of
knowledge but I almost see it the way we
treat children like I don't want you up
to you to have to struggle with the same
things I've struggled with I want you to
remain in your magic for as long as
possible as a child I want to protect
that world that you're in and God
telling them like don't eat of this it's
almost like I know those apples I have a
poison in them that's going to begin to
corrupt your mind and I don't want that
for you yeah dosage you know don't eat
regions of assets it's basically what
he's telling them she's like you know
what I'm gonna eat because I think the
fruit is uh the psilocybin mushroom or
the um
they talk about the tree of life and the
tree of uh knowledge of Good and Evil I
think is what the two different trees
were the mushrooms that grew that had
the chemicals that basically gave these
animals Consciousness and uh she
overdosed she took a huge huge dose of
it and then Adam's like what and she's
like Adam we are and he's like wow and
then he's like all right I'll join
because he loved her so much he's like I
want to understand what you understand
and God's like this is going to change
everything do not don't go down I'll
explain it from Ian's perspective so the
aliens came to Earth and were doing
genetic experiments and they created
these little like you know human monkey
dudes and then they were just like you
no eat mushroom no no and then he leaves
and then one dude comes in he's like you
should totally do it and then the
female's like Ron eats it and the male's
like oh and then eats it and they're
like what just happened dude I'm naked
except here's where I like and this is
part of why I disagree uh one of the
reasons I would disagree with that kind
of interpretation is because it suggests
that man was
lower than he is now before he committed
the original sin and now he's risen to a
higher level of Consciousness so but I
believe it's the exact opposite original
sin brought us down but let me let me
ask you like what was the Apple
it's been debated I mean it actually
isn't even called an apple it's called a
fruit but we refer to it as an apple and
some people uh in other cultures
actually find that kind of funny like
wait you like specifically call them now
I mean it makes it sound less
metaphorical it doesn't really matter
but you know um some people think it was
a fix some people think it was a uh
what's it called a kins or something
like a the five it could literally refer
to like a product when fruit meaning
like the the app the product of a
laborer or something you know what I
mean it's probably you know it may have
been just you know not not really
anything it's just
um it was a test right will you obey or
or oh it could have literally just been
like a like a little fruit that didn't
matter at all and what's funny though is
once once they took of that fruit and
disobeyed and committed sin uh you know
um
gothan banished them out of Eden and
then put a a flaming uh uh he he put an
angel with a flaming sword
to uh to basically block them block them
from getting to the uh tree of life
right which is interesting because it's
like why did he not do that with
now the first tree right so
um it was a test
and uh once they disobeyed and and fell
into sin if if they then took of that
um life tree uh that that may have like
you know like sealed their fate forever
I've actually heard that I'm not yeah I
think God wanted them to uh take the
fruit I don't think he wanted them too
but I think he probably would right I do
I think interestingly humans have free
will right yeah yeah and then we are
supposed to be virtuous people and then
if we are and we're faithful because if
they did if they did not take of the
fruit they would have been you know like
in the sort of childlike State Foreign
there's no opportunity to prove you're a
good moral virtuous person unless you
enter this this space I don't know if
that's true well because they could have
proven that they were were good and
virtuous simply by not eating it because
they would have obeyed God but there is
precedence Catholic tradition there's
precedent in the Catholic tradition for
referring to the Happy fault right so
obviously I mean this original sin every
horrible thing that has ever happened in
the world happened because of this sin
we can't underestimate that right every
genocide Every Act of rape or child uh
sexual exploitation everything every
horrible thing that ever happened
happened because of this original sin I
mean the severity careful it's
understated
women but it's the fault of all of us
but um or it's the fault of Adam and Eve
but there's an additional element here
which is that all being true Christ was
able to show us this this uh beautiful
love and God was able to show us this
beautiful love
and that's why it is sometimes referred
to as a happy fault so when we very it's
it's a very interesting thing we hear a
lot of stories about Jesus and the the
travels the things he did but but that's
like watching a TV show you only get the
Highlights right like people even says
that there are we couldn't write down
everything right so if there's any other
things that there are shows where it's
just like you watch an episode then it's
like three months later and something
happens and there's stuff that happens
in between what was like the daily life
of Jesus yeah I think you went to India
and learned Reiki yeah
I'm saying like for you Sheamus who you
are faithful and a Believer what is
written what is known about like a
regular day I think that they're so
in terms of Christ's daily life in part
you can just sort of look to Historic
context how people lived in that part of
the world I think there's there's good
indication that he woke up early
um there's there's moments in scripture
where he's we um oh man I'm trying to
I'm trying to remember the exact passage
a little bit but well yeah I mean so the
apostles were were fishermen and we
actually get uh the the idea that they
weren't very good at it either because
they're they're not really catching fish
and then Christ helps them too nice so
you just look at daily life in that
region and probably something like that
I mean he was telling people that he was
the son of God and the response was well
is this not Joseph the The Carpenter's
son and so it's clear that it was a more
ordinary life in some sense no I think
the most incredible things that we do in
our life are done in the most quote
unquote insignificant moments to what we
would perceive as significant or
interesting it's the day-to-day little
conversations you have it's the boring
in-betweens and yes they highlighted the
interesting stuff in the Bible but I
think it's like when life slows down and
you have meaningful conversations with
people that have nothing to do with
media tweets none of that those are the
real meaningful moments and also by the
way I just found it it's in Mark chapter
one where it mentions Jesus getting up
early before the sunrise is going out to
parade I just started getting up early
it's life-changing giving that sun crazy
no it's it's true getting up earlier and
this is something I've always struggled
with especially someone running a
business and then having this crazy
upload schedule and having a bunch of
random stuff thrown at me they don't
expect like it has been hard to get a
good consistent sleep schedule but
whenever I'm able to get up in the
morning I always have just a far better
day it's clearly what makes it to do I
saw a meme video of this girl she's like
I know I'm gonna sound horrible I really
hate to tell you this all but waking up
at 5am going to the gym eating a healthy
smoothie it actually does make you
happier that's right I know I sound
awful I know I'm disgusting but it is
better well I did it for about one month
and it was life-changing and then I just
I fell back
no I know I know exactly what you mean
but then you remember you go that was so
so good for me and it's fascinating
right because we live in a culture where
you're never able to suggest that
someone's miserable because of their own
choices if I'm miserable it's either
because Society has done something wrong
to me or because my own existence is
fundamentally corrupt there's just
something wrong with with my body and do
you think that there's nothing I can do
to get past it but no it's all of the
things that everyone gets uh lambasted
for saying will help your mental health
will help your mental health with of the
exception of of course severely mentally
ill people okay if it's aside hey many
maybe even them you know some early
sunlight you know what's weird though
why do you think sad music is so popular
like there's something I I people like
like feeling emotional because it makes
you feel yes people like trust things
like that that smoking until 3 A.M
listening to sad music that's emotional
people actually get addicted to that
feeling and the problem is when you can
feel it in a vacuum as like a moment in
time that's processing an important
emotion it's a good thing but when
there's people that get addicted to that
constantly and all they listen to is the
depressing music all they do is enter
that world I've noticed this with
algorithms on the computer if I have an
algorithm that is constantly politics
talking about the end of the world or
you know gendered I've deliberately gone
out and I've followed a bunch of
feminist accounts to balance out all of
the woman hatred on my timeline I want
man hatred so that I can look at it all
and see the absurdity of both sides
together and be like wow this is like I
see this happening on both sides clearly
it's somewhere in the middle you guys
are delusional blaming each other you
have your environment your friends the
people you talk to they 100 impact you
and people who think they can keep a
sane sober mind in an environment that
is completely dripping with a bias
they're delusional you you are probably
in that cult right now and you don't
know it we I got notified of some drama
just now from a couple hours ago I'm
going to address it so um there's a
there's a viral edit of jazz Jennings
life and talking about the things that
have happened and I responded to it with
where is Rhonda sandis this is all
happening in Florida question and we
know that a lot of it what's going on
with jazz Jennings as a trans child uh
did not happen in Florida but they do
live in South Florida now and have even
expressed I believe they've talked about
their fears about what's going on in
Florida and I got a response from
Christina Pusha and from Jeremy
uh Red Fern and these are both this is
Jeremy is the Deputy press secretary for
DeSantis and Christina is the um uh
personal uh she's still the president
secretary I believe and so uh she said
uh what do you say I regret to inform
you that Jess is 22 and the governor
doesn't have a time machine I'm not sure
which state these procedures have
happened in but uh if it was in Florida
Jazz was a minor before descendants was
governor and I I just kind of feel like
they're either completely ignorant over
what we've talked about in the show and
what's being addressed Jeremy said but
how it's supposed to get outrage clicks
pretty sure that there's video that
there are videos showing that jazz is
not willing to take a a medical device
and place it into a wound to separate it
and uh has been severely depressed and
the mother is saying it's your fault and
the mother's threatening to ring the
neck of jazz Jennings so if that's if
they're currently living in South
Florida and when I say like what's going
on where is the distance Administration
in your responses he doesn't have a time
machine y'all can go yourselves
because that's a pathetic response very
pathetic there you go my heart just goes
right out to Jazz Jennings either
they're in South Florida the child the
the the jazz is 22 and an adult but that
doesn't change the fact that if somebody
is being if if the mother goes on TV and
says if Jazz lets the wound close I will
ring her neck it's kind of like do you
do nothing is there not even a statement
to be made like we're concerned about
this just nothing just you don't have a
time machine okay great I'm real
confident in your Administration well
there's there's so many factors there
there's the one like family that's so
much pressure trying to appease your
family make sure they're happy they're
the people you're going to be closest
with your entire life and then two once
it's already done once the surgery is
already done Jazz Jennings has no choice
right now but to Double Down Double Down
Double Down triple down and I don't know
if there's any help at that point like
you said that you're right it is a bit
of a dismissive statement oh we don't
have a time machine but man what a just
horrific kerfuffle no one can get out of
my heart totally goes out it's just it's
smuggling to me that you could do
someone to that you could do that
someone not end up in prison it's just
like literally the most pathetic
response and it and and like what what
little strength I saw in the in The
Descent Administration is gone because
we had the issue with Trump's
extradition and Rhonda Santos response
was I'm not going to get involved and
I'm like bro just saying no like you've
got to do anything other than be like
you're not extraditing him he can choose
to go but I'm not gonna I'm not going to
you know be like I'm not going to let
you do it uh and I was like okay but
it's fine because I think Ron's still
like a really great governor and he
still does speak out he's doing a really
really good job but like I think this
the reason they're really mad I think
the reason is pressed people are like he
doesn't have a time machine is because
they're they're impotent in the issue
they they will not go up against a TLC
Channel Celebrity trans kid despite the
fact the mother is on TV saying if you
don't do this I will do it like that's a
threat of assault to insert a medical
device into a into someone who's an
adult who is saying no to it and their
responses doesn't have a time machine
you know what man that is just so
pathetic like the moment the
show comes out there should be a the
defense Administration should be like
we're putting our AG or or our our
criminal investigative division because
they're gonna have footage from the that
show and it looks like that's probable
cause of a threat of force against an
individual you know who's clear like
I'll put this way Jazz Jennings not
doing the dilation indicates Jess does
not want to right as an adult the mother
then says I've wake woken her up and
said if you don't stick this in you I
will and then later said if she leaves
and it closes I will ring her neck at
that point should you be like I think we
should have a criminal investigation it
sounds like a coercive control which is
a type of inter-family violence but it's
kind of like taking a medication that if
because if she doesn't dilate it it'll
seal up and she could die from
infections yeah it's kind of like I will
make you stay alive so it's not really a
threat of violence although it is a kind
of a it is what was already done was is
obscenely violent but just like the
destroyed this this person's body if if
an adult is taking a choice in in and of
themselves and an individual then says
like if an adult comes to another adult
and says if you do not do this thing I
will do it I will insert this into your
body like I think at the very least
right there there it warrants an inquiry
of some sort but more importantly when
she says to the camera if it closes I
will ring her neck that combined with
the other one implies there are threats
of violence against Jazz to do this and
the The Descendants Administration could
simply be like a woman on television
threatened said she will choke her child
who is an adult if she does not insert a
medical device into was it like a
flipping statement for your mom like oh
I'll ring her neck like yes was it like
that or was it she's more like I will
literally
she said if Jazz goes to college and
that thing shows up I will ring her neck
but was that like a I can understand
that being interpreted both ways like it
is the combination of the two sound
bites yeah that I believe warrants at
the very I'm not defending the parents
don't get me wrong
to say something if you say on Tuesday
at 4 pm I'm going to ring the person's
neck that becomes an imminent threat of
violence but I'm talking about the
combination of these two statements the
one I wake Jazz up in the middle of the
night and say if you don't do this I
will you argue well it's a medical thing
but then you add to it her saying I will
ring your neck yes we understand
threatening to ring someone's neck may
be a figure of speech like I will be
very angry with you but she already said
she wakes Jazz up and says if you don't
do this thing I will do it to you
combine those two things and now I think
a reasonable here's what I think I think
that the descendants Administration is
terrified to actually take a strong
cultural stance on what appears to be
severe severe abuse stemming over a very
long period of time but now this family
lives in their jurisdiction and is
currently engaged in questionable
behaviors that I believe are abuse maybe
they're not fine I'm saying that the
bare minimum there could be a inquiry
but they won't do it because they're
scared a left will go nuts DeSantis will
will have no way to deal with the with
the Press I think that this shows shows
me and what my concern is with the
Santa's presidency is that he will
compromise negotiate and bend to the
Press
he won't come out and just be like
that's horrible Donald Trump's the kind
of guy that if he saw that clip on
Tucker he would immediately go out onto
a stage and back what is this thing with
this woman did you see this she's saying
she's going to stick the oh my God Trump
will just come out and start saying it a
lot of this I think hinges on Jazz and
what Jazz wants because if Jazz goes to
the authorities and is like she won't
leave me alone she's forcing me then I
think there will be an inquiry but you
know when when somebody is you know
being manipulated like that their whole
life it's it's hard for that to happen
right like
that's why I'm like he's probably under
some you know how psychological control
or something how about the what happens
right now is the Santa Administration
sends a letter to the production company
saying it's in order to preserve video
and evidence then just says we are going
to issue a subpoena as part of an
investigation and we're going to look at
this footage and see what's there and
then start looking at the behind the
scenes clips of what what may be abuse
and that's the that's a that's a that's
an inquiry that maybe stops and says we
think it's bad but we don't think it
goes that far
instead it's like you don't have a time
machine that's not an answer dude like
this stuff's still going on the show is
on the air this person is depressed
morbidly obese didn't go to college
talks about severe mental health issues
and you have videos of the mother saying
very very awful things I think they're
like if there's one thing government
would do it's like if there's a reason
for law enforcement to exist it is to
prevent that from happening to a child
but I know but no I understand that they
aren't anymore but I'm saying the fact
that that was able to happen in the
first place but but the age the age of
majority in instances of familial abuse
it you you don't stop being protected by
the law because you're an adult now a
coercive relationship where you're being
like if it was an adult woman an adult
man and the man said to the woman
something about sticking something
inside her and then later said he'd
bring her neck he'd be arrested in two
she she would have to be the one that
came to the police and presented that no
no imagine the scenario imagine the
scenario a video emerges of a man saying
I wake my wife up in the middle of the
night I say if you don't stick the this
thing I will do it and then later says
like if she goes out and she says I'm
going to ring her now this doesn't she
would go to the house presses charges no
are you sure if if so the state is the
one that presses charges not the
individual but I don't want big debt so
government being like he said
no I'm talking about a guy saying he's
he's holding he's waking up a woman in
the middle of the night and saying he's
going to stick something yeah like a
needle like in a medical assistant like
some intravenous diabetes and then later
says if she doesn't I'm gonna rain that
would result in the cops knocking on the
door and saying ma'am we'd like to have
a word with you
dude I have seen guys get arrested for
so much less there's a video of a woman
hitting herself with a hammer and then
her husband gets arrested like it is it
is it is remarkably easy for a woman to
call the cops and say my husband
threatened me they show up in two
seconds but she's the one who made the
report neighbors can call and say I'm
hearing a fight next door and the man's
screaming and they will take the guy out
of the house and say go somewhere else
for the night
we have we have a video we have Decades
of footage we have all of these public
statements from Jazz that are
questionable and then the mother saying
these things on TV and the Santa's
Administration is like well we don't
have a time machine so best thing I
think Thomas who is have compassion for
jazz be here for jazz and am Jazz make
the decision anyone who has transitioned
as a child I have infinite sympathy yes
infinite because there's no way like
someone in that psychological State you
can and you can never expect them to
come out and say what was done to me was
wrong because the amount of weight and
like the pillars of salt and sand
they're gonna have to undo for their
entire vision of the world and their
future
you know that's accepting my future is
over who I am is over my my chance of
having the family that I wanted all
these things is over that is like such
an overwhelming ask of someone all you
can do is is give them sympathy at this
point in their life and maybe you know
they can work through that eventually
but holy like they have been so set up
for failure it's not even funny I agree
a little bit it's such an unbelievably
uh difficult and strenuous uphill battle
for that person to be able to like ever
be capable of seeing the truth about
what was done to them the nature of of
who they are the fact that you know
their their identity was taken from them
rather than affirmed the fact that they
will never be able to have things that
the rest of us just take for granted
that we can have I mean it is it's
barbaric you'll have different things
though Jazz you'll have a different life
than a lot of people but it'll still be
pretty cool yeah you can yeah there's no
need
exactly well and I think it's important
like when we discuss these things we
want to speak
very clearly about how absolutely
horrible this is to deter people from
doing this to speak truth to make clear
what's happened while also allowing
people who have had this this horror
inflicted upon them to know that they
need not despair
they can still have a good a very
beautiful and wonderful and important
part of life has been taken from you but
that does not mean your life doesn't
have meaning and that does not mean you
can't have a good life Something
Beautiful was stolen for me but that
does not mean that you need to Despair
and that there will not be good things
in your life yeah there could be
beautiful hundreds of millions of kids
that feel out of their body right now
Jazz that you're speaking to that you
could guide through life and help them
you know reduce pain I mean that's
just ease the pain and suffering of of
young people and adults even that are
going through you're you're in a the
resolution of power and really
importance right now the response I'm
getting from the DeSantis people is just
like false arguments sophistry and
deflection jazz is an adult and DeSantis
has banned gender surgeries so that
people won't grow up the same pain and
regret I said it's happening now did you
even watch the video are adult are
people allowed to force medical devices
into adults against their will in
Florida apparently the answer is yes
apparently the answer is right now if
you're in Florida and you have an adult
child and you say if you don't stick
this in you I'll do it and then later
saying publicly I will ring their neck
if they don't that's totally fine not
questionable in any way
so okay Florida I don't know if if the
mom if if the mom was to be charged who
who would bring the charger so that
would be the state the state always
bring the charges and that's the
prosecutor right yeah people people make
the mistake of thinking that an
individual pressing charges is the one
bringing the charges they're not so in
fact there's many circumstances where a
person let's say you're like walking
down the street and a guy comes up to
you and shoves you and a cop watches it
you can say officer I don't want to
press charges typically the cop will say
okay sure but for for two reasons one
it's it's easier just to say fine and
two without a complaining witness
there's almost no case however if the
cop watches it happen he can say buddy I
don't need you I witnessed it I'm taking
the report sir you're under arrest and
mirandizing is only a part of an
investigation so I love these videos of
leftists being like oh you've not been
read my rights they're not cops don't
have to read you your rights if they
know you committed the crime but if so
if can you go and retroactively enforce
a law that was passed after the ACT
actual no and you shouldn't be able to
but I'm not talking about that see what
they're doing right now is they're
conflating that jazz went through these
surgeries therefore I'm insisting they
use a lot retroactively I'm literally
talking about a video that came out of
them in Florida and the mother saying if
you don't do this I will and if you
don't I'll ring your neck I can tell you
dude if there's a video of jazz being
like no stop stop and the mom coming at
her and putting something inside her
body then she'll have to knock on the
door so my point is if I hear fighting
next door and I call the police and say
I hear a men and women fighting they
will show up and at least knock on the
door and say can we speak to you a lot I
did that once the cops will separate
them and say what's going on here we
have a video of the mother saying if you
don't do I've woken Jess up the middle
of the night and I have said I've taken
the dilator and lubricated and said if
you don't stick this in your vagina
and then she goes on I'm not gonna
repeat what she said and I'm like that
right there should warrant a knock on
the door and their response is we don't
have a time machine you know what man
sure let's go to super chats and we'll
see what you all have to say okay wait
can I throw a social hand grenade in
quickly yeah please
so you have kind of the right wing side
this is actually a stone toss meme I
think they talk a lot about how we need
to make it illegal for child uh sex
Transitions and genital mutilation do
you guys think that genital mutilation
against men as children in the form of
circumcision should be legal I think no
I think I don't think so I don't think I
don't think that those two things are
equivalent but I don't think it should
be legal no it happened to me and I've
never really suffered so I don't really
care uh so the issue is I think it
results in like removing 70 or whatever
of nerve endings
and also no one so well there's a couple
different important points to make about
this well so again well I do not believe
that circumcision is at all equivalent
to what they're doing to children now
with these like quote-unquote
transitions I I still am very against it
I don't think it should be legal and
also
the kinds of medical circumcisions that
are done today from what I understand
are very different from the ones that
were done in the Bible too now again the
circumcisions the New Testament makes
clear are not required we're supposed to
have a circumcision of the heart but
even so people will start talking about
like Jewish communities but even then
that's not the kind of circumcision
where you move all of it from what I
understand
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the share with your
friends become a member let's read
Brett tesdall says Tim as I write this
you're getting a shout out for your show
last night on The Mark Levin Show oh
cool that was a great show last night
very cool
Tiffany Garrison says hi Tim I checked
and your crochet Roberto Jr arrived
today my teens and I loved making them
for you trying to get these teens off
their phones if you want more for the
store let us know we will check it out
we'll have the well we'll go pick it up
Amos Moses says look into the story
about two guys facing life in prison for
Engraving
schematic of an NFA item on a metal
business card the ATF even had
difficulty using the schematic to create
a full auto rifle with a couple of
failed attempts okay so I think of an uh
we say engraving a schematic of an NFA
items yeah okay uh yes it's a metal card
with a drawing on it and if you cut it
out it makes a component that can be
used in a weapon and they they've
criminally charged these guys it's crazy
fluffer boy says Ian I love you you're a
beautiful human I love your name fluffer
boy
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats let's scroll down and see what we
got Beau Rai Cho says yo that show was
lit last night yeah
well Ryan shout out to Lance thanks for
coming down man 12 hours bro of course
now the response from the left is that
Lance was and and like was was not the
right person for the debate yeah I don't
think we won't really debate I don't
know I didn't expect a debate it was
cool to talk about you know
there's always a debate because what
happens every time a lefty comes on the
show is before the show starts they say
something that's just absolutely untrue
and then there's like nothing that can
be done I can't just sit here and be
like Oh okay that's fine the funny thing
is we're talking like dude if we were
talking about the banking industry we
would have just been agreeing all night
so the issue is like hey there's a video
showing people in Canada being dragged
out of their homes during covet
lockdowns no that never happened I'm
like there's videos of it it's like I
can't just say like you're right it
never happened even though I've seen the
videos like they they just say things
that aren't true and then I'm like okay
well there are videos I'll pull them up
and then the other issue is like
when it when it comes to studies it's
it's all selective so one of the big
contentious moments was there are two
peer-reviewed studies about desistance
being 61 to 98 and he says I reject
those because a meta-analysis of 51
studies says otherwise but like a
meta-analysis is not a peer-reviewed
study it did not go through science is
the opinion of researchers who read
other opinions there were 55 studies
analyzed 52 or three of them had some no
one no one can lie like someone who can
talk about numbers you look at all the
studies that came out that were
highlighted in the New York Times
Atlantic everything talking about how
illegal immigrants commit less crime and
then sure enough you have uh you know an
analysis done of those studies and they
don't usually register illegal
immigrants as such until they're in
prison and then they get their status so
when you're using the data based off
just arrest it's like duh you're not
going to be getting I'm I'm no longer
persuaded by studies I know I know like
it's probably you know you have
to look at the methodology of the study
I'm not going to read all that oh yeah
most effective but what are the most
effective ways to use studies when you
work in politics no is to know your
opponent studies so you can know exactly
why they're nonsense yeah well if
someone wants to do all that research
all power to them let's read some more I
don't get into polls anymore all right
cold Deluxe production says just
correcting you from two days ago Iron
Dome has been test against both scud
Mach 5 and 6 ballistic missiles and low
alt subsonic cruise missiles and has
been successful the Rockets fired by
Hamas are smaller than drones it can
stop uh would it say it says it can
drone swarms so stop drone storms I
believe
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Batman has no
superpowers but he's a superhero yes he
actually does it's called Peak human
it's act that that's the phrase for uh
in comic books when a person has
seemingly absurd powers that they say
aren't Powers so for instance Batman can
teleport when he's talking to he's in a
bank vault with one exit and then the
guy turns around and then he turns out
Batman's gone and it's like he has no
okay come on is that like Daredevil it's
called being rich he Bank transferred
the guy who was guarding the bank and
he's like sick it'll be like he'll be in
a room and the guy will be talking and
then turn around and look at something
when he turns back Batman's gone that's
not a that's not possible in the real
world is Daredevil Peak human it's movie
Daredevil actually has superpowers It's
a lazy there's like a bat yeah what's
Daredevil's power he got splashed in the
face with a chemical that took away his
eyes but Amplified his senses Beyond
human Okay hypersensitivity
hypersenses and so he can see like sonar
in 360 Degrees that's awesome did they
make a moon Night movie they made it
they made a show and they just ruined
Moon night through that one when I was
younger but that was like uh it was like
Marvel's Batman right yeah and now it's
actually just an Egyptian superhero
who's like at mummy Powers mummy power
yeah so like Moon Knight was just a rich
guy in a suit who was kind of like
Batman but a little crazier and then
Moon Knight the show is about a guy who
is crazy but has the ability to summon
the power of the Egyptian gods and then
you know whatever I guess it was okay
show I guess
equibus says What About Kids in the Hall
come on Lauren Canada Kids in the Hall
was legit what's Kids in the Hall oh
it's like a sketch comedy show come on
Dave what's Dave's last name
yes
there's a there's a funny skit where
these two guys are like looking at their
neighbors gazebo and so then they lift
it up and steal it and then and she
comes out and there's like a hole in her
yard where the Gazebo was and she sees
them in the yard partying so she calls
the cops and then the cops are like
where did you get this gazebo and
they're like we bought it from our
friend and like where is like they go to
an abandoned house and they like throw a
rock at the window and this crazy guy
looks out and the cops like excuse me
sir did you sell these boys at gazebo
it's like no no and they're like you may
not remember us the Gazebo it's like you
sell these boys anything and then he's
like the Gazebo and then I think it's um
Dave Foley Dave Foley he's like I did
sell these boys a gazebo and then you
know it's just a funny skit you gotta
feel like old school Canadian card
and then I was like so fascinated with
them I didn't take a picture so clearly
I'm lying if you don't okay nothing
exists if you didn't film it I love it
Jeffrey Rook says well if she's doing
math CPS should get involved because
she's trying to kill the chat but I mean
meth is illegal so guy last night was
pretty smart but always defaulted to
default narrative have fifty dollars for
YouTube clipping that delicious moment I
couldn't believe that he actually said
that that that's not what I expected him
to say said what that you oh so Sheamus
said a woman can do whatever she wants
to the baby if it's inside he said no
but it's her body so she can choose and
I said what about meth and then he said
well child protective services could get
involved and I said you know what why
and he was like because then she's just
trying to intentionally kill the child
and I was like wait a minute but what
like I don't understand what you're
saying she she's a he you think she's
allowed to terminate the life of the
baby at it with a doctor
but she can't do anything that would
intentionally intimidate the life of the
baby makes no sense it's like its own
special trolley question like if you
pull the lever then it'll die via meth
or it wasn't a question it was it was it
was it wasn't a trick question I thought
his response was going to be something
like oh come on like meth isn't a
medically necessary procedure about
making the decision of whether or not
you're going to have a child it is an
abusive drug that causes damage to your
body and won't even necessarily kill the
child it could just cause serious injury
and harm to both you and the child
there's a big difference I thought he
was gonna say something like that
because it was not a trick question I
was like trying to see where he would
draw the lines morally instead he just
outright said you can't intentionally
kill the child and I'm like wait what
see this is why you should just have a
show where you like quickly run across
the table and dress up in a different
costume and debate yourself as a leftist
it's like playing chess I can argue
their positions better than them
Colt warrath says Tim I have been
looking into the Nephilim for years
please have on dear and Sharon Gilbert
to cover this topic for you they are not
set by Eric Derek Gilbert Oh Derek there
is a good guy they are not uh Seth
Heights and there are threads that run
all through the Bible I so one
recommendation I can make too and I've
shouted them out on the show before but
I think Jimmy Aiken would be a very
interesting guest for any uh religious
discussion
uh especially about these matters he has
a podcast called Jimmy Akins Mysterious
World where he goes into a bunch of like
weird conspiracy theories and stuff but
from a Catholic uh perspective a
Catholic Chris placek in the regular
chat said Tim's wrong about Moon Knight
it's always been about the Egyptian gods
but you can never tell if it's real or
he's crazy oh there you go oh like
American Psycho
or if he's actually done all these
things you can't tell if he's if his
actions are good or bad
that's him
Trevor Lynch says the Nephilim are
spoken about and alluded to all over the
Bible that's what the conquests of
Joshua was about clearing the refane
giant Nephilim Clans from the land also
one Peter and Jude is referenced I
wonder if they're the Denise Evans you
know that that other hominid yeah so I
don't think so but yeah that's
interesting like an ancient hominid that
wasn't a homo sapien yeah I think
Hancock talks about the uh
people have about like why The Uncanny
Valley exists like why humans are afraid
of things that look like them but aren't
quite them and it's like well clearly we
evolved to have this uh reaction because
there was something on Earth that it was
our mortal or physical enemy looked like
us but wasn't quite of course Lauren I
have another explanation what if it's
because we as humans are more than pure
mechanations and even if you get
something that's identical to us in
terms of appearance we know there's no
soul I hope so because ai's coming AI
all right
yeah I think Andrew G says Solving last
night proportional response debate in
every jurisdiction in USA a threat of
deadly force is treated the same as
actual deadly force
yes
just gotta adhere to the eyewitnesses
rusta says I can answer this now God
granted Us free will because without
free will we cannot truly love God
created us for love and without the
possibility to reject God's love it
would not have been true love amen you
know it's kind of cliche but love really
is the main
theme of scripture really so I love it
it transcends everything the Greeks have
it broken down to eight different types
yeah there are different types erotic
love there's familial love love of
friendship you know JN says the reason
for the tree of knowledge of Good and
Evil is since Adam and Eve were created
in a perfect world and in order to
exercise free choice you need at least
one option that is opposite from
everything else which was good also that
same tree was a was a form of the law
well that's similar to what I think you
guys were saying I think that give it
everything's perfect but you're given
the option to do the opposite otherwise
you're not really good if there's no
chance to not be good you're basically a
robot at that point in the Garden of
Evil they said God was there if it was
actually a dude that was speaking as God
and then like over time as the people
die and other people are born they
become the god of the time and they're
like now I am God and as a story is
written it's always about God but it
happens to be whoever that human was at
that time it's not like the Matrix
number six
this is one thing that disturbs me about
the garden story is I've been reading
C.S Lewis the weight of Glory uh lately
and at the beginning he talks about the
idea that a lot of sin and a lot of um
you know the depths of humanity that
people get to they they usually are
pursuing them because they're trying to
fill something in themselves they've got
this intimation of deprival and they're
just exercising it in the wrong ways
they really want to find that wholeness
they want to be loved so they go to they
do a bunch of drugs orgies this that
because they're trying to fill a hole in
themselves and then I wonder what and
that makes sense to me we've all got
this longing for something outside of
ourselves but what hole in themselves
were the people in the garden trying to
fill like what was the
uh they that that's an interesting
question that's a very interesting
question I mean how does he temper you
will be like God
um there's an argument to me like there
was nothing because there was an
original sin there wasn't necessarily
like a hole to fill but they still chose
apparently wrong God knew dudes with
flaming swords and maybe they wanted one
of those well also I think I I also
think that part of that too is with this
idea of the angel with the Flaming sword
not being able to return it we'll never
have Paradise on earth right that's just
not possible for us I guess until the
Oscar town when God recreates the world
but none of our ideologies none of our
attempts to create heaven on Earth are
ever going to be successful garden we
got some trouble Deuce Bigalow says Tim
did you see Christina peshaw and Jeremy
Redfern take you to task over your
unreasonable standards for DeSantis you
should have those two on to address them
you know what no I'm gonna totally
concede the argument outright I
Surrender if you're on camera saying
that you have to wake up someone to
threaten to stick a medical device into
a a a a a Neo vagina and that if they
don't do it you'll ring their neck in
Florida that is okay and if there's
nothing they can do about it I accept
that's Florida's current standard and
that there's no action that will be
taken if there's one thing I really end
of story this is one thing I really hate
about this whole like it's Trump versus
the Santa's thing it's like you know you
you have this issue and you know there's
a real soul that you know that um you
know that is now suffering in in the
story but they don't care it's about how
does this you know is this protocantis
or is this pro-trump and you know how
does it benefit my guy like it's just
this brainless uh Civil War almost and
it's just it's so boring too like it's
just I don't know I I don't like how
that
is going right now I do not care about
Trump versus Santa it's I don't care I I
I actually love them uh both terms muted
on my timeline right now
but yeah it's about jazz it's about what
is right to be done for them well no no
I'll I'll say it if if in the State of
Florida there is no action that they can
take if a person's on camera saying they
wake a person up in the middle of the
night and say if you don't stick this in
you I will do it and that if they don't
do it you'll ring their neck if that is
not a standard by which law enforcement
can take any action well that's
unfortunate I guess we should reach out
to Christina I was gonna say that'd be
Fire episode they've already they've I'm
pretty sure I think we've both invited
both of them many times yeah
um and I don't know good publicity for
all let's do it that would be good I
think yeah
standard give them a platform to say why
yeah I would love for them to come and
explain why it is that DeSantis cannot
take any action in that regard when this
person is saying this because I'm not
talking about the surgery that happened
you know five years ago out of state I'm
talking about the video right now
showing that this stuff currently
happens in South Florida
I think you've got evidence that jazz is
severely depressed you've got reason to
believe that this is the cause of it the
mother on camera saying you are Your Own
Worst Enemy it's your fault I'm like
these are all very clear signs of abuse
which like I think in any other
circumstance they would have law
enforcement on here let me read this one
this is from Matthew Ruth says the man
can be bleeding from the wife attacking
him and the police will take him right
there's a there's a viral video where
they have a guy an omen walked on the
street and the man screams the woman and
is pushing her and everyone runs up and
shoves him and so you back off then they
inverted it and have the woman literally
striking the man and everyone laughs at
him yeah it's a real thing yeah
all right we'll read some more Robert
bechman says I'm going to Japan next
week for my first work installation as
an electrical engineer please pray for
me or at least wish me luck PS great job
last night well good luck thank you very
much I got you
where are we at
londerware says you should make a high
caffeine light roast and call it focus
with Focus that's a really good idea and
we got people very smart watching the
show
yeah okay
and km says hey Tim really enjoyed the
culture War episode today it was really
funny that was uh me Sheamus and Lauren
and here we are now there's another show
yeah it was a fun episode go watch it
youtube.com timcast that's right what up
today and it's more of just like a loose
conversation about a whole bunch of
different stuff
very fun
Nathan C says the irony is Tim is mad at
DeSantis over Jazz but DeSantis is the
only governor in office fighting back
against transgenderism with real policy
so I didn't come out and say Rhonda
Santos is a bad guy for not doing it I
didn't come out and say I hate Ronda
status I said where is Ron DeSantis this
stuff is happening in Florida and
instead of being like hey Tim glad
you're concerned here's all the things
that Rhonda Sanchez is doing we'll take
these into consideration and and we'll
talk about it they came out like well
it's too bad we don't have a time
machine and then I started having all of
these Protestant as people started like
crapping all over him like dude I don't
think you guys have standards you know
it's a purity test and you failed it oh
I don't care though like you know the
irony is that I'm mad at DeSantis when
did I say I was mad at DeSantis I am
criticizing the response from his PR
team who turned this into something that
it probably should not have been
they probably should have responded with
Ronda Santos is doing these things to
stop this stuff from happening and
that's all that would have happened all
I think I think all I literally did was
where is Ron DeSantis right
where is Rhonda Santos this is all
happening in Florida
because they currently live in South
Florida
I think the issue is it's a sore spot
because they're not taking action and it
makes them look good to be you know
but you know like I said look okay I can
see if that's the kind of stuff that is
allowed in Florida then that's what this
currently allowed it is a very tough
decision socially right now that's a big
part of why I want to I mean personally
I don't know the conversation I don't
think so I think like like I mentioned
if you hear a man and a woman yelling
and call the police the police will show
up in two seconds without the woman
saying anything and sometimes the cops
will even tell the woman it doesn't
matter we're taking the husband out
because we are concerned like there
there are many instances where the woman
lands at the door and say everything's
fine please leave and the cops will say
no you know so like I don't know if
that's entirely the case it probably
depends on where you live absolutely in
the United States women will answer the
door and the cops are like can we have
you come out and speak in private she'll
say no and they will still say ma'am you
have to come outside because often when
women are being battered they tell the
cops to leave so some often the cops
will say we are not going to leave until
we do an interview because there's a uh
probably I guess I listen to a lot of
True Crime and like the main gripe with
the True Crime YouTubers is they always
say like all the police were called to
the residents like eight times and they
just walked away and never went in and
they did a checkup but if that's like
always the gripe in all of these like
murderers and of course that happens too
why it's a story about a murder right
yeah so this the reason why sometimes
cops will not take no for an answer
they'll say we have received an
emergency call giving us probable cause
to enter the home ma'am step out of the
house and then they'll check her for
injury or whatever often they'll just
say okay we're sorry to bother you have
a nice day sometimes they'll say to the
guy we're concerned something's going on
why don't you leave and come back later
sometimes it's really bad and they just
arrest the guy because the neighbor made
the and they're like better to have him
spend the night in jail they're not
these are these are I guess I'm from
Canada where it's like all the persons
on their ninth probation and they just
like assaulted someone again and their
cops won't come that could be where
we're going
but I mean like they actually have a low
credit score if you don't have a
criminal record yeah so here's
a reasonable of me to say that following
those clips a state police officer would
knock on the door and say can I speak
with you in private is that unreasonable
um the issue is I don't think it is but
the issue is if that were to happen the
entire National media would go after Ron
DeSantis as it appears he's preparing
for a presidential run and he doesn't
want the heat I think if Jazz wanted it
it would be completely reasonable for
other people to want it for them they're
both that's easy so I'm like people
people who are being abused by their
husband like women being abused by their
husbands stay with them often right it
does happen it does and what are you
going to do sometimes the cops will be
like you got to catch them in the act
and there are many circumstances and
many jurisdictions where the cops are
like there's nothing we can do because
the woman is not speaking up and
speaking about this guy and then like
you said in the ninth time and then the
murder happens like there was a case
um yeah it was such a sad one there was
Asian University student I can't
remember his name I wish I could but his
dad had like threatened to kill his mom
like a billion times a lot of people in
the chat probably remember this and then
eventually his dad had like made the
explicit I'm going to kill your mom like
this week and he went home and killed
his dad before he could and he
eventually he actually the jury let him
go the first time and then they were
able to get him on a legal weapon
possession charges later and send him to
jail for like the rest of his life or
whatever but it was like there were so
many explicit threats the police have
been called a million times and they did
nothing I'm gonna read this one from
Josh Berg we'll do uh we'll do one more
the craziest thing Lance said was when
he tried to shame you about another
person's Sensations then at the end he
said I want more freedom more people and
more orgasms to which I said that was
weird so the left does this thing where
well I'll say this about Lance he had a
lot of canned responses and like that's
why I asked him like standing with Matt
Bender Matt Bender says you think trans
people don't exist I said what does that
mean Lance said you're in favor of
forced birth I'm like Define that what
does that mean I don't know what you're
saying because these are just like I I
heard someone say it I'm repeating it
and so in in this circumstance the left
has this repetitious tactic of why are
you talking about someone else's junk
that's weird and I'm just like bro
you're not going to shame me I'm having
a conversation about fact things and
human development well it's right you're
not going to appeal to my like to
shame because
like to quote Rick your booze mean
nothing I've seen what makes you cheer
that was there's a little bit of Shame
going in both directions when you were
like there is a transgenocide and you're
the one that's causing it but you guys
got past it it was a little moment where
it was like you kind of got
misunderstood but there's there's no
shame for me because these people hold
no esteem in my mind like yeah people
who are in favor of of like performing
these things on children I am not going
to go oh no do they think lowly of me oh
geez the groomers think poorly of me I'm
like I don't care these people are evil
I've seen what makes them cheer yeah so
when he's like isn't that weird you
think that I'm like bro you are the guys
doing the sex shows and then wanting
kids to be present well this is you're
not you're not shaming me oh this is
right out of Rules for Radicals though
accuse your opponent of what you're
doing so they've implemented an entire
systemic legislative and medical
structure that allows for you to
mutilate children's genitalia and then
when people say oh my gosh they're
mutilating children's gonna tell you
they go so why are you talking about
that that's so where the you'd focus on
that well it's almost like you've used
the full force of all of corporate
America in the United States government
and many state governments to push for
the mutilation of children and so now
people need to talk about it and to
represent Lance a little bit he did say
he didn't like sexual stuff with kids he
was specifying drag with kids which
isn't always sexual nuanced conversation
he said well he said burlesque is always
sexual but drag isn't when drag is
literally burlesque burlesque for gay
men you could do non-sexual I think you
could do non-sexual person Ian there are
burlesque shows where a portion of it is
not overtly sexual a woman will come out
and address and dance on stage then at
some point in the show she may take off
her outer layers it becomes burlesque
and so what his point was which is
incorrect is that because a portion of
drag shows don't involve over you know
exposure that therefore sometimes it's
not it's like well not all burlesquez
either but furthermore drag is often
over sexualized features a male will
come out he'll have fake breasts and
fake hips to sexualize the performance
otherwise he would not need to Dr to
have those Prosthetics to to simulate
secondary sexual characteristics yeah
yeah but so I'm I'm positive that Lance
is not into sexualizing kids that was
not what he came here to talk about he
didn't intimate that or anything so the
issue is the moral standard from where
all of us are regardless of whether
you're conservative traditional liberal
is
drag is a sexualized thing
certain elements of it are not well sure
but like going to a sex shop some some
things they sell there are unrelated to
sex they might sell like a vitamin pack
for energy and you can say like well
that's not all sex related it's like
well but the reason they're giving you
the energy pills is because it's a sex
shop you know what I mean so you're
doing the drag show it is themed or it
is centered around sexuality lgbtq stuff
is literally a community that has an
identity based on sexual characteristics
introducing that to Children is grooming
because the purpose of grooming is to
introduce the lightest form of something
to a child so that you can open the door
and then coax them in so the purpose of
these uh the the the drag Story Hour
drag pedagogy article that James Lindsay
often references says get the glitter in
the carpet that can never be removed
what they're trying to do is say take
the bassist the base element of the sex
show which is the drag performer
themselves and have them do something
seemingly innocuous so that parents
won't understand what we're doing but
the person they then write exactly what
they're doing to get glitter in the
carpet that can never be removed and
that way the child then says oh drag
performances are good and then they go
to one and then what do they see the
sexualized performance yeah you can make
the argument that it could become a
slippery slope but I would think on
purpose if I went in and read stories to
kids in my bathing suit that would be
more sexual than if I was in a dress
well no because the thing about drag is
that's their fetish costume and they're
wearing their fetish costume in front of
kids
right the drag is sexualized it's it may
not be erotic
right but it's it's sexualized because
like as a man you know I I don't wear a
dress because I'm a man right like it's
on the basis of sex it's not it's not
erotic it's like I'll put it this way
let me put it away
a guy walks into a bank armed and with a
ski mask on did he commit a crime I
think so why you're not allowed to wear
ski masks in winter
we're in a constitutional carry state in
West Virginia you're allowed to carry a
gun I don't know and you can wear ski
masks in Winter Ian why are you trying
to criminalize an innocent guy who's
just cold and and defending himself and
if it was during covert you probably had
to wear a mask too oh yeah you know I
mean now now you can make an argument
you want to arrest an innocent man is he
brandishing the weapon I didn't say that
no of course not it's concealed that I
don't know people should be allowed to
go so so you get the point even though
it's legal to wear a mass food I think
even though it's legal to bearing
Society The Mask thing is grooming
Society let's stay on points and I
change the subject my point is this we
recognize that wearing masks legal for
the most part a ski mask in Winter ski
mask exists because you're cold and you
want to be able to talk and look and
you're allowed to have guns in a
constitutional carry state and we can't
assume you're a criminal simply for
having these things but I'll tell you
what if you walk into a bank wearing a
ski mask with a gun don't be surprised
if the security guard comes up and says
sir I'm gonna need you to step outside
take the mask off leave the gun in your
car your your people are concerned about
what your intention may be and then he
goes oh you you're accusing me of being
a burglar that's the most insane thing
I've ever heard there's nothing
inherently criminal or or bank robbery
about wearing a ski mask and bringing a
gun into a bank you're going to be like
dude don't try me right so when a drag
queen with drag being a burlesque
performance goes up to children and you
say hey we're kind of concerned about
what you're introducing these kids to
and they say oh oh now you're it no if
it's burlesque you can do non burlesque
drag that's that's contentious no yeah
yeah that's right you you are right in
the in the same sense that you can walk
into a bank with a scheme asking a gun
and you're not intending to rob the
place but no one is going to accept that
because we get it
well I mean drag is not a gun a
sexualized perform a weapon you know
it's just wearing a dress I think but so
so drag literally is gay burlesque no
burlesque is sexualized drag Ian you're
wrong dude look up the definitions let's
get over this it's you can wear a dress
and not be sexual but that's not what
drag is men wearing sexualized costumes
remove their clothes on stage for money
that would be stripping that's what drag
is drag is wearing clothing of the other
sex so when Dad said when that when an
11 year old boy whose name I'm not gonna
say yeah that guy but they call that
drag they call it child draft
and it becomes you're trying you're
doing it Lance does and creating a false
definition to defend the practice of
grooming dude you Eddie Izzard would
wear drag on stage when he would perform
he wasn't doing burlesque did he have
lipstick on yeah we did the whole thing
what's the purpose of lipstick I don't
know to simulate ovulation
did you know do you think when a woman
comes in here she's sexualizing children
you take a woman God I didn't wear a
lipstick today yeah exactly you think a
woman wearing lipstick is sick trying to
sexualize kids there are degrees to
which we accept certain things women at
Hooters expose their cleavage and
children are allowed in there but we do
say like okay if a kid goes in there
we're not gonna scream and cry about it
maybe I don't think they should be but
right some people say because there's
lines inside I wasn't allowed to go
lipstick emerged we believe because when
women are ovulating their lips are and
cheeks are bright red so women begin to
simulate these things right so when you
have a man
put on lipstick wear a dress shake his
hips and wear fake breasts that oh the
fake breasts I agree
no use word I could just wear a dress
that would be drag okay I'm not talking
about you're this I think I think we're
defining it differently too here because
all I mean I would still take issue with
that but drag queen Story Hour it's
never just a dude throwing a dress and I
would still be against that but it's
there's a lot more to it like Tim's
mentioning there's the fake breasts
there's an adult makeup or the the
person who wore the prosthetic uh
breasts and genitals yeah that's all
sexual but they call that drag Story
Hour
the clear response here is to bring this
individual chocolate and tell them to go
home and lay down because they are
clearly ovulating we gotta wrap things
up we've gone late so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcastirl or you can follow me
personally at timcast Lauren do you want
to shout anything out infringed damn
gonna come out like next week or the
week after at least within the next few
weeks you got watch it gonna be on
timcast.com maybe Tuesday Tuesday
probably that sounds like a lit day to
watch infringed
right on at Lauren understand Southern
follow me same thing watch infringed I
want people to follow you guys on
Twitter too give me your Twitter John
duto j-o-n-d-u-t-o-i-t
absolutely I believe it's Lauren
Southern
on Twitter if I'm not mistaken at Lauren
underscore Southern don't forget the
underscore it's important whoever stole
the one without the underscore screw you
stole it from you
um I so what I want to shout out is the
Novena to St Joseph we're on day five of
it right now we're praying that for the
working class in this country in this
tumultuous economic time for The Unborn
and also for our enemies people who we
very much disagree with and think are
doing bad things that they may see the
light so if you all want to go over to
my my Twitter account that's one of my
most recent tweets has a link to that
Novena pinned there
yeah well I'd like to hear more about
that maybe next week uh Matt binder I
know you're out there I love you man hit
me up let's do a show together someone
told me you like my stuff a fan of yours
and a fan of mine and also I want to
shout out normal World which I brought
up early in the show it's uh Blaze TV is
putting it out it's Dave Landau and
quarter black Garrett I had the
opportunity and uh blessing to do an
episode with them it's up on YouTube now
normal World drug Topia is the name of
the episode that I was on Alex Stein was
in it great time great people check it
out and I will catch you later
I just want to shout out uh Jeff Garnett
uh Kellen told me that you were a fan of
the show
um felt like it was worth doing thanks
guys I'm sure.com catch me on Twitter
let's argue thanks for hanging out
everybody we will see you all with
various Clips throughout the weekend and
then we'll be back on Monday cheers